foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
awesome
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
it's Championship day and Wesley saw has
to beat Magnus Carlsen twice to win the
aim chess rapid and I'm going to ask our
experts in the studio to play Star bets
will we see a grand final reset Simon
don't look man guys no cheating for that
to happen Wesley so has to beat Magnus
Carlsen in the first match and we will
reveal the bets later for now it's time
to get to the action welcome to the
champion chess store
[Music]
okay
and there you go the first surprise Oh
No rookie four oh
[Music]
yeah
not a bag does just resign
and then lastly so it doesn't for the
second time today he books his spot into
the M chess rapid Grand Final against
Magnus Carlton
and I have the bats in my hand we will
reveal these later Magnus Carlson
meanwhile got what he wished for Wesley
so as his Challenger in the Grand Final
it could be a short day of Chess on a
really long day of jazz and to keep us
on top of the big fight in the studio
Grandmaster David Howell Grandmaster
Simon Williams
and international Master Danny Ranch
Danny we get Magnus versus Wesley in the
Grand Final what can we expect today we
all get what we wanted Magnus Carlson
gets what he wanted I think what we can
expect is what happens but not just two
of the best players on the planet right
now but two of the best players in their
generation throw down in a high stakes
match it's going to be a blast and uh
Magnus I think he I think he wanted this
and we're gonna see if he's up for the
challenge
is Magnus up for the challenge and is
Wesley up for the challenge uh Simon how
impressive was Wesley yesterday uh very
impressive I mean he seemed very strong
in all areas of the game the opening the
middle game and the ending and um he's
gonna have to keep that up to date have
a chance I mean it's just getting better
and better every game he plays he
started very slow but now he's in real
Wesley overdrive gear
and he needs to keep that overdrive gear
on because he needs to beat Magnus
Carlson twice David what will it take
for Wesley to get by today it take
Wesley being in top form it might take a
bit of luck and it will need him to just
play Move by move game by game if Wesley
takes the lead I think he's uh got a
great chance but he cannot let Magnus
strike first that will I think pretty
much end his chances he needs to get his
kind of positions from early on and
yesterday we saw incredible chess from
Wesley so we started with the battle
between Wesley and threesaga with a lot
on the line and wall number eight Wesley
so his chest was from another planet
foreign
the compensation and look at Eduardo's
decision taking H4 blowing open White's
King I like it I love it I don't think
Wesley should have done this I agree
this loses a bit of control and gives
Eduardo what he wants he is so stressed
out he knows he's so close in this one
he's starving it around and look at it
through zaga he knows he was so close
but now it is falling apart and that is
the end of the game Wesley so holds on
it's full of traps and full of tricks
and Wesley's like you saw the reaction
he's like oh crap here we go like what
is this kid got in store with some sort
of magical preparation Oh No rookie four
oh
he reacts he missed it how did he
removed he thought Black's Rook was
going back to D4 to defend the Black
Knight oh my God that's just honestly
that's a mistake of Youth you gotta call
it what it is now it's a hopeless
position just uh about to be three pawns
down yeah it's it's over not a bag does
just resign and with that win obviously
so it takes the lead
had to capture this Pawn instead but
look at the wreckage of his structure
this is one-way traffic suddenly Wesley
in control good call there Danny the
Knight joins the attack he takes the
pawn and it's a big mistake is there a
finish here David
I think it's something to do with Knight
D5 and the B6 square is calling my name
I'm freaking out what is it it's all
it's a dead lost situation but he just
offered a draw
Wesley so asserting his domination and
the elimination bracket there meanwhile
Magnus Carlsen has been in the winners
bracket from the very start from Monday
will today be the first victory for
Wesley or the second one for Magnus
Carlsen on the tour and Dani with the
qualification into the season playoffs
on the line how much does today mean to
Wesley I think it's a really good
question because you just made me
realize that I worry a little bit about
Wesley's mindset you remember what he
said in the interview that he was
already excited having gotten back to
the losers bracket because at least he
was playing in division one again and
that's a common tale with Wesley he has
to believe he can do it he can't settle
on the fact that he's only guaranteed a
spot to division one he's now knocking
on the door to Toronto and he needs to
strike here he needs to take his chances
against Magnus and have a confident
mindset yeah 100 I mean uh this is his
chance he's got a chance here if he wins
this he's got his uh he's got his
Toronto ticket and he might not get
another chance so uh he's got to just
play real high quality and be very
confident today this is something that
holds him back I think in the past is
confidence yeah and the format of the
tour this season means that this is
extra high stakes not just for Wesley
booking his ticket potentially in
Toronto but for everyone else in the
tour if Wesley doesn't win a a slot
opens up Magnus will take the Victory
and uh for everyone else it comes down
to tour points so Magnus is actually
going to have a lot of supporters it's
kind of funny to me you don't normally
have a lot of people rooting for Magnus
because they all want to take him down
but today I think there's a lot of peers
watching who wouldn't mind Magnus
Carlson getting this thing done in three
games and just relieve the pressure
because as as David said that opens up
another spot V the tour points only
eight players will make it to that
season final playoff in Toronto Magnus
Carlton has already booked his ticket
this one is a big big moment for Wesley
so and he is a fighter and he hates
losing
how much you hate to lose and I hate it
so much
that probably one of the reason why I
make so many draws
um yes it changes your tournament so
much when you have a good tournament and
then suddenly you lose a game or two
uh it completely Alters the direction
the path that you take
I guess I'm kind of per player who is
trying to look for Perfection where I
make no mistakes and like if I make no
mistakes in a game like no blunders or
maybe even just very slight errors then
I'll be very happy it doesn't even
matter whether I win or I lose
so my main thought was to play a good
game but two draws equals a win so
that's that's always my I think from a
young age I was always trained to take
it one game at a time always play for
two results you know a win or a draw
[Music]
and that's always been my mindset all
these years so maybe that's why it's
very difficult to change
[Music]
that that trick always if you win more
games than you lose and then you're good
to go so
one of the best players on the planet
Wesley so but sometimes to win you have
to be willing to lose Danny is that
something for the world number eight
Wesley so is that something that comes
in his way to become world number one
you know one of my trainers a famous
trainer uh once told me that you could
classify everyone's personality into two
buckets those who love to win and those
who hate to lose that interview reminded
us that Wesley so definitely fits in the
bracket of hates to lose what that means
on the board is your personality is
going to lean a little less risk maybe
not take your chances when you have it
and so
I think that Wesley has to kind of stay
confident he has to remember he just won
the global Chess Championship last year
and that he can do this Simon 100 I mean
is uh that thing about the glass is it
half full or is it half empty that kind
of Springs to mind that confidence uh
that people have I mean you know this
Optimus there's pessimist and it seems
to me that Wesley sometimes doesn't have
that belief in himself which he should
have you know he's one of the best
players of all time and he needs to have
that belief to beat Magnus Carlson yeah
my big takeaway from that interview is
firstly that he will have to fight his
nature that kind of risk of us uh uh
style of Chess but also he did mention
he takes it move by move game by game
and that is neither today it's been the
theme of Wesley's tournament struggling
losing the first match but ever since
then especially yesterday playing two
different matches it feels like he's in
the zone in the moment right now and
that might help
confidence and not letting the fact that
he needs to be the world number one
twice today let that get into his head
that's going to be uh the key here for
Wesley so but he's done it before he had
a phenomenal run in the 2021 Champions
Chester season beating Magnus Carlsen
several times winning so many of the
2021 season events making Wesley saw the
man to beat look at that horn that horn
is a monster there's just no stopping it
whatsoever I mean Magnus has an amazing
chance of striking back but Magnus
blocking the white Bishop is that just
came over here
there's nothing to be done
this fights back wow look at that
reaction from Magnus Carlson it is a
comeback from the world champions and we
are heading to Armageddon he's going to
lose on the clock Wesley if he doesn't
lose on the board he still needs to save
it on the board especially after that
last move waits for it getting active
Magnus wins wow that Magnus Carlsen in
Armageddon it's pretty sick like I came
back five times when I sort of needed to
win absolutely insane I I'm just so
happy to uh pull through
[Music]
Agnes Carlson they're celebrating after
many losses to Wesley store in the 2021
season wessie so won the Skilling open
in 2020 the Opera Euro rapid and along
the way took down the then world
champion they have so much history
between them they've been tour Rivals
Rivals for a really long time as well
know each other extremely well David
what's the psychology there and how much
does that affect not just what's going
on the board but also the fact that you
know each other so well yeah it's pros
and cons firstly knowledge of the
opponent can help you know their
weaknesses but the problem is they know
about you too and for Wesley Magnus
knows all of his openings there I've had
it myself in the past with Rivals when
you play them multiple times in England
I'm thinking I faced Michael Adams
plenty of times and it can be awkward
there will be moments in the game where
you know your opponents in their comfort
zone and that kind of past history gets
in your mind a bit yeah it's tough I
mean just when you know someone's game
so well it's really hard to surprise
them right I mean you can overthink
things as well you think I need to do
something different and then you can
start playing more dubious things I mean
talking about Rivals we might have to
chat about ours a bit later on
Juvia's things indeed we've had many
dubious
experiences together haven't we but no I
mean I think you guys made great points
and I'm looking at their overall record
and first of all how many times have
these guys played each other as compared
to the peers in their generation I'm
actually curious about that stat because
that's a lot of chess games Magnus is up
24 to 19. but 34 draws really speaks to
Wesley and how tough he is to be because
Magnus doesn't like to draw people I
talked about Wesley being a guy who
hates to lose Magnus is a guy who loves
to win so he wants more dubs in the in
the win category and Wesley has only
five games total behind in terms of
decisive results so this is we aren't
just hyping this up for no reason this
is a matchup that is really an
interesting one especially when both
players are on form and 90 18 wins
against a player like Magnus that's not
a start that many top players can boast
about but Wesley so he has been in the
losers bracket since day one and then
goes on to win every single match we
haven't seen that storyline in the
Champions Chester season so far he finds
himself in the Grand Final David how
impressive is that it's extremely
impressive it's not coincidence that
Wesley was called magnus's Nemesis for a
long time beating him in several matches
2019 World Championship which a random
world championship and yeah just the
path he's had in this tournament has
been top-notch impressive stuff yeah
it's been like it's been like a kind of
weird car Wesley you know sort of uh you
start it up you get him going he's like
and now he's like and he's like you know
he's just getting quicker and quicker
and better and better in each game I
want to make a really quick point
because what you just mentioned about
the Fisher random World Championship
isn't even as part of that head to head
because it was Fisher random so that
tells you that their overall score
lifetime Wesley is right there with them
and that was an event that whether it
was Fisher random or not had the highest
Stakes a world championship title and we
all know that Magnus Carlsen really
wanted to win that event he did it so
I'm just I can't be more hyped for this
Magnus Carlton yet to win official
random World Championship Wesley so has
done that been there done that and uh
can he do it again he can look for
inspiration at his countrymate Hikaru
Nakamura the only player on the tour who
has risen From the Ashes In The
Champions Chester this season from the
losers bracket and gone on to win the
Grand Final can of Wesley so pull that
off against world number one Magnus
Carlsen today a lot on the line
including that golden ticket to the
season playoff and the winner will also
get this very unique Trophy and so can
the fans there is a fan edition of this
trophy which gets you a VIP ticket to
the 2023 CCT finals in Toronto later
this year in December you can go make
your bids on chesschamps.io and find
yourself watching all the best action in
speeches in Toronto later that's gonna
be a big event Danny to be huge and
we're gonna we're gonna have uh tickets
available obviously as you said there'll
be VIP experiences and eight players
this time for those who know that we did
the cgc the global championship in
Toronto we only had four so it's gonna
be eight players gonna be epic and uh
hopefully we'll see you there
there's still a long way to get there
because the players today fight for the
aim Chess Championship and this is the
regulations for our grand final we will
start with a best of four rapid 15
minutes with the three second increment
every move they make two and a half
points wins the match if it's a tie we
get the bidding Armageddon if Magnus
Carlton wins the first set he is the
champion if Wesley so wins the first set
we go into a grand final reset which
will be a best of two matches 15 minutes
again with a three second increment if a
tie we get Armageddon so Wesley so first
needs to win one match force a grand
final reset and then uh try and take it
there and there we have the players
ready Magnus with his chairs and Wesley
with his trophy cabinet
yeah
will he add a trophy with a brain in it
to the cabinet and we're going to find
out sorry David you're about to jump in
I was just going to say that it is a
deep horn opening what is Magnus gonna
go for Queen's Gambit there we go I was
afraid for a moment it would be a London
system but uh okay Queen's Gambit will
it be accepted declined here by Wesley
he's got to do it the long way as you
mentioned there Tanya he's got to win
this four game match and then a two-game
match but first he just needs to survive
this game with black and uh a draw I
think Wesley would be very happy with
it's the Catalan now and I want to build
on the stat that uh Tanya said because
you made the point that Hikaru is the
only one to have been in the losers
bracket to come back and win a grand
final Wesley has already done something
that no one else in the tour has he's
officially as of right now the first
player to lose in the first round and
make it all the way because Hikaru made
it and won the Grand Final but he didn't
lose in the first round so already
Wesley having done something impressive
but can he keep his mindset and win the
whole thing and that it wasn't just the
score line on that day one it was also
his form felt so shaky but some switched
when he got back on day two and ever
since we've seen two different versions
of Wesley this tournament yeah we've
talked about that a lot as chess
commentators I know I've had many
conversations with with Robert uh Hess
about it where sometimes you see players
start early and for whatever reason
because they're back up put against the
wall and they got maybe they got lucky
and they didn't get sent home it ends up
really really helping them be on form
for the rest of the event right your
cage gets rattled a little bit and you
wake up and you know these guys are
human sometimes you need something to
kind of surprise you or or help you
smell the roses and and Wesley has
gotten better with every match yeah you
said it yourself Danny the first day was
really on wesley-like it was just like a
different person and definitely a
wake-up call and uh okay he has to wake
up here Wesley his head is in his hands
he's looking down he's trying to
remember something uh this last move by
Magnus as far as I'm aware is quite rare
Wesley so here he's using an antidote to
the Catalan opening that Vladimir
kramnik first Payton and yeah he needs
to speed up here okay he develops his
Knight very natural move thoughts on who
this opening will favor Magnus known as
an expert here well I think you
mentioned it David I think this this
first game with Magnus on the white side
is so important uh and really he has to
avoid losing this one I think if Wesley
you know doesn't get a result out of
this one it's going to be an uphill
struggle with the black pieces and I
mean looking at the position it seems
like a fairly typical position so far
white has the better Center more Pawns
in the center he has this great Catalan
Bishop this is one of the real strengths
and um in theory as well I mean playing
a move like that Queenie one uh you you
have to have looked at this before to
play that so quickly because it's not a
completely obvious move and uh you know
I I guess still fairly even but it will
yeah we'll find out soon but I think
you're making really good points not
just about how Magnus is playing the
moves he's playing but the fact that
he's playing them so fast look at how
much time he has and Magnus understands
that chess is a game of psychology and
he understands that some games or some
results are more equal than others and I
really believe that Magnus know how
important it is for him to strike really
because no one wants Wesley so to get
momentum no one wants that I mean Magnus
Carlson experienced that in 2019 and he
knows how good show can be so Magnus I
think not just wants to win but he's
playing quickly for a reason I think
he's really trying to flex a little bit
of that opening prep and and maybe maybe
intimidate Wesley a little bit maybe it
is a positional Fred here David already
I mean if it is white to move white
would better lock down on that backwards
Pawn Yeah potentially potentially yeah I
was looking at the other side of the
board Simon but you're right if for
example black plays a very slow like a
lazy move here just H6 for example then
uh you could totally lock things down
and this Pawn like you say it's fixed
forever it can never step forward and
you're going to Target it very easily
along the C file uh this is maybe one
threat I'm wondering about magnus's
queen move of course it's protecting
this Knight as well I'm wondering if the
bishop will land on A5 this is often an
annoying tactic a very thematic idea in
this type of Catalan and uh yeah the big
question here is as well uh can black
break out there are issues with this
bishop on the edge of the board the
White Knight might go and just trade it
off a bit later on at least harass it
and uh yeah just to point out as well
the Catalan is all about this bishop and
this bishop looks pretty good right now
black needs to strike out in the center
or do something in order to neutralize
the pressure already three four minutes
up on the clock Magnus I think
objectively Wesley's fine though I mean
the position is roughly level and and
remember Wesley also played Bishop fh5
which got a quick response Queen E1 so
they both kind of knew what they were
doing I feel like mostly in my opinion
the critical things that are happening
right now are not on the board they
might be in Wesley's head and uh the
fact that he's taking so much time is is
nerve-wracking if you're a Wesley fan
100 I mean it's I mean just talking
about the position as well I think it's
well known that in this position from
the black side you've you've got to
really try to play C5 at some some
moment we talked about this pawn and
that that must be a critical move here
maybe and he has played it
um this and and again like you said
Danny Magnus just putting on the
pressure immediately just saying I've
looked at this position Wesley I know
what I'm doing do you know what you're
doing and immediately he attacks that
Queen with a with the idea that David
mentioned and uh this is certainly he
he's showing great psychology here I
think he realizes that Wesley is is not
such a confident player and he's
question questioning that already really
nice multi-purpose move there by Magnus
which makes the move with the queen
which makes the move that he just played
possible also defending the Knight now
when your opponent is blitzing out moves
right out of the opening does that have
this psychological effect on you where
you start feeling that have I not
prepared enough double guessing yourself
David how does that affect you yeah it's
actually good and bad when your opponent
blitzes firstly if they're blitzing it
means you've played moves that they
expect which is normally uh kind of
translated as you're playing good moves
uh so you're if you play moves that the
computer suggests of course they know
what to do but it means that your moves
are pretty decent too the downside is
you don't know when the preparation ends
maybe they've gone deeper this has now
move 17 maybe Magnus is prepared up to
move 25 30 Wesley at some point needs to
throw him off needs to try something new
so it can be scary as you say Tanya what
are the chances of the this being Magnus
carlsen's 2021 World Championship prep
actually think there's very decent
chances of that I and for those who
didn't follow that match obviously him
and yonda promise he got into uh a few
Catalan battles and you know the game
the preparation the games may be shifted
away from it but I think that happens a
lot with world champions right you
prepare a ton of things and you don't
get to use all of them but they stay in
your mind and every once in a while they
have a chance to creep back into your uh
your tournaments and I think Magnus is
flexing some sort of prep because he
doesn't have to play this quickly he's
doing so to sort of send a message that
I know this position better than you and
uh you better have come prepared and
it's not a strategy we're used to seeing
from Magnus in Rapid games usually he's
trying weird and wonderful openings and
trying to surprise the opponent as early
as possible this is like Ultra Main Line
move 18 now still more time than he
started with and he's going for all
these ideas that we mentioned Knight F4
Bishop A5 it's uh impressive stuff do
you think having the rest day yesterday
for Magnus is a good bad thing losing
momentum but having extra time to
prepare for this match I think it's
definitely a good thing I mean uh he
he's been playing so much chess recently
he's been on a roll but you do need to
re re-energize obviously uh is
it's really hard to say how hard work it
is playing chess and how how it can
really just drain your energy I mean
people think oh as a game of chess it's
a bit of fun you play it you play it by
the fireplace for your dad and you know
it's entertaining but no it's it can be
pretty torturous in a really nice way I
mean what I say to people it's like can
you imagine the hardest exam you've done
in your life you know you normally do an
exam for three hours you're doing this
uh for four or five hours you're doing
it every day and you can't you you can't
let your brain slip at all you have to
you have to be totally 100 in the zone
you can't think about anything else you
can't you really it's really stressful
it's really intense and that is a very
unique thing for chess I think actually
well also because it's a it's a it's a
game with high stakes you're also
dropping your adrenaline right it's
exhausting it is right and he had to do
it not just once in terms of the exam
but twice yesterday against the turizaga
and and Notre back of course and so
yeah this this doesn't look like a great
story I mean look Magnus has more time
than he started with Wesley is about to
be under half of his time remaining and
um objectively the position is still
okay we shouldn't panic because remember
all Wesley needs to do is draw the first
game with black right and and keep
himself in the match not to lose first
but but Magnus sending a message and uh
it's impressive right now
yeah just looks disastrous from a
psychological standpoint here for Wesley
we'll really have to see how tenacious
he is and how focused he is because I
think most of us here myself included we
would be panicking I would just be
Frozen right now as Wesley seems to be
just thinking how is he going to survive
this how is he going to get Magnus for
the first time thinking on his own
incredible speed there by Magnus Carlsen
double the amount of time that Wesley
has and more time than what he started
with right now and that last move it is
going to create an imbalance in the
position as we will see minor pieces
being traded off Wesley's Bishop can't
really survived for too long which means
when there is this kind of a knight and
Bishop trade that we can expect critical
moments and decisions to arrive with
Wesley six and a half minutes on the
clock that can come back to bite him
yeah I mean he's already he's already
half the time down and Magnus is up
Magnus has more time than he started
with and I I you know maybe obviously
being the body language expert of course
as you said you can see that Wesley now
is folding into his hands there's body
language is a little bit slumped at this
moment in time and he's just not very
happy is he and uh also to be honest
looking at the board it looks like it's
quite a dangerous position we see he's
played another move here but uh he's
going to lose the bishop pair uh Magnus
loves having the bishop pair just look
at White's light Square Bishop that is
such a fantastic piece I mean you might
even be able to come in and attack The
Rook on B7 you know at some point you
probably don't need to do that but um it
looks actually a little bit dangerous to
black as well you know chess wise yeah
I agree and I want to say that I think
one of the hard Parts about this bishop
Diego first of all psychologically this
is the first moment Magnus has been
thinking so from Wesley's point of view
that makes you almost more nervous
because now it means uh oh did I move
away from his 2021 World Championship
prep is he about to punish me
um but I want to point out on the
analysis um board David that one of the
problems with Bishop d8 is you're not
actually threatening to take A5 I think
that position would improve White's
chances right because those A6 and B5
clones are such targets whether we play
Simon's Bishop E7 or not the moment he
played Bishop Diego was like this
doesn't feel good white can play moves I
mean like Rook C1 right Rook D1 you can
build on the position I think Rook C1
would be natural right and
and what is black doing next how are you
untangling a queen on E8 and a rook on
f8 right it's like the old lady who
swallowed a fly it's a it's a we got one
problem after another here on the back
Rank and it's hard to relieve White's
pressure
on the plus side we know he's the uh
former world champion at Fisher random
Chester get his pieces he'll definitely
look like they need to be magnificent
played Rook C1 what happened to the
woman who swallowed the fly by the way
so what ends up happening at the end of
that story she she eats a horse things
get weird on the form yeah everyone's in
therapy and we're doing good and before
things got too weird on the comments wow
wow good call there on you with that
Rook moving in to Target the sea lion
and once again are we going to see these
Dynamics where Wesley perhaps
overextending on the queen side but
could also leave him weakened without
the light squared Bishop on the board
for black
yeah I mean it's uh it's just quite
tough to you know those Queen side pawns
might look quite nice from black uh but
are they strong are they weak I mean
here they come Wesley's pushing them
forwards and but they can just as easily
be targets because white has two Pawn
breaks that hits them there's one this
is the obvious Pawn break just trying to
trying to again we we say the nibble the
rabbit nibble you know just nibbling
away at that structure that's my rabbit
there and uh just trying to
thinking Magnus is the goat but he's
clearly the rabbit he's the the rabbit
God goat I don't know
goats nibble they they can goats they've
got very nice beards as well aren't they
so just I I assume but um where are we
going um but this is a standard standard
move and uh you know you've got to hold
on to that structure if you're black
here as soon as it starts splitting up
uh it can it can become very dangerous
so I'm very fearful for Wesley's
position here uh I mean again you
pointed out the fish are random pieces
I'm not really liking this fish around
him set up at the moment
yeah I've got to ask a question here to
everyone can you even see a logical move
for Wesley I don't see anything natural
at all and when you're under five
minutes you want kind of at least easy
play even if you're suffering
objectively I don't see anything you're
pinned you're tied up your pieces are
massive I'm I'm not kidding that I mean
depending on what happens in this match
don't want to speak too soon but I've
already made a note of an interview
question for Magnus should he win like
was this 201 2021 World Championship
prep because he has played so fast and
so well if we were to do an instant
replay this is a borderline perfect
Catalan for white Wesley on you know
didn't really do anything wrong you
almost feel bad for him right but he ran
up against a buzz saw with a whole bunch
of leftover prep from a couple of World
Championships ago and and he's down on
the clock and much worse White's Bishop
here is phenomenal the queen side is
being undermined this is this is this is
tough stuff and that shows how much
Magnus wants this yeah this tournament I
mean he's already qualified for the tour
finals but he wants to win now he wants
to beat Wesley so he's using his best
openings and normally Magnus keeps a lot
secret and he saves them for big
occasions but this is one of those
clearly and the pawns are separated
Simon yeah and uh America's still moving
very quickly I mean he can't be in his
preparation now but he's 10 minutes up
on the clock and he's starting to use
those Pawns in the center uh Black's
past pawn and this is something that
often happens in the middle game in
chess you get a past Pawn but is it
strong or is it weak and I think in this
situation it's it's just quite weak it
could be so yeah I mean I'm it looks bad
for Wesley I have to say at the moment
and I think uh David you've made a very
good point Magnus come in with his a
game here uh we saw he was playing 186
at the start of the tournament now he's
probably using his world championship
preparation which he had a team uh
prepare so it's uh gonna be tough but
Wesley is still in the game Magnus
Carlsen with the better Pawn structure
Wesley saw low on the clock and two
weaknesses on the board we were talking
about how much of this how deep is the
prep here but very often when it's World
Championship prep even if it's not this
exact position that Magnus has had
clearly his understanding of the Catalan
and the familiarity that he has with the
middle games is so high and it feels
like he's just out playing Wesley slowly
but with every single move and uh David
we've been talking about magnus's Farm
uh form not farm farm and it just seems
like this is the first tournament on
this season that Magnus hasn't gone into
a single Armageddon to get a win is this
some of the best chests that we've seen
from him yeah it feels like Magnus just
this last couple of months is really
perked up I think it it was uh we can
trace it back pretty much to Norway
chess where Magnus in the classical
portion didn't win a single game but in
the Armageddon he was winning most of
them so still decent shape rapid but
ever since that Blitz rapid tournaments
he's been racking up the uh the
victories and yeah this is just a master
class so far I think maybe if we just
jump in and show a couple of things to
viewers at home we talk about the
Catalan opening a lot we talked about
the Catalan Bishop earlier with its nice
range it's blocked temporarily but this
is a dream and this is textbook stuff
you want the pawn Center you want the
bishop pair you want everything and of
course if you have weaknesses to Target
we've been talking about this Pawn then
later on this is uh yeah just a very
easy plan for white I agree with you
Tanya Magnus in great form right now and
just natural moves you can bring your
Rook to the center so many tempting
options he's going to keep blitting I
think what you said Tony is a really
important point because I think
sometimes fans confuse deep prep with
deep understanding the preparation from
these World Championship matches or any
high level preparation by these guys
does go to a certain move and sometimes
there are concrete traps that your
opponent might fall into but a lot of it
is to reach a goal and then they spend a
lot of time playing those positions they
get training games in those Pawn
structures and with the middle game
ideas so they tend to then know that
position much better than their opponent
so at this point it may not be relevant
whether Magnus has specific moves from
here on out the time is indicative at
one point the time was indicative of him
having all the moves right he had more
time than he started with he was
borderline movie right but now the time
is indicative that he understands the
position better that he knows he has an
advantage and he knows what the ideas
are right and a lot of times that's a
really good lesson for people in order
to develop into chess Mastery you can't
memorize all moves in chess but you can
memorize the formations the ideas the
types of tactics that occur in common
Pawn structures Etc so Magnus is just
all over this game a short way of saying
it and I I think one of those moments
which shows his understanding in this
position Simon was when he moved that
Queen from C1 to E1 because it set up so
many ideas in the position for white the
ability for the Knight to retreat and
then eventually go on to trade blacks
Bishop the ability for White's Bishop to
move forward and put the black queen in
an uncomfortable spot and I think
Queenie one was quite the star move out
of the opening 100 and I I think that
was definitely in preparation you know
he played this move but he also as Danny
has been saying had a plan in mind when
he played this there's probably a plan
that he's looked at where with his
seconds I I'm sure this is some deep
preparation and he knows what kind of
structure to move into I mean this is so
important I think for many people maybe
watching this who love chess it's like
okay you you play the opening but you've
really got to know what you're trying to
do in the middle game you know not just
memorizing the moves but what kind of
what kind of Pawn structure do you want
where's your P where should your pieces
go what kind of Pawn structure are you
trying to stop your opponent getting and
the it's amazing that not many actually
lower rates players think in this way
and that's in the media immediate way to
to improve uh improve your standard and
you can see that from this and saying
all that you know Wesley is in the game
he's not Material down uh he's kind of
solid I say kind of solid because I can
see this there's something happening in
the center at some point but at the
moment he's okay and um Magnus now
having his first think which again
anything that can give Wesley a bit of
confidence is good for Wesley at this
moment in time and uh he just he just
puts his Rook one square forwards there
which doesn't look that challenging
David and move and move like that for
Wesley no I agree it doesn't look like
the most kind of ambitious move here by
Magnus but the idea is to swing the
other white Rook across uh White's Rook
next to the king now on F1 not doing too
much and actually Magnus decided maybe
it wasn't uh kind of the best Square to
just centralize it there he's keeping
his options open and then okay Wesley
used the time that Magnus was thinking
that to play Knight to A4
pressure on White's Bishop we've talked
about how that black porn on C4 is
isolated week First Step was to blockade
it
how to get it now that's the big
question for Magnus what's the next step
yeah and David can you also break down
what are the Strategic decisive factors
in this position that the players can
try to fight for we've been talking
about Magnus having this great opening
understanding he's done everything right
but for black as well there are things
that Wesley's got trumps that he's got
so what do you think is going to be the
development and the factors that are
going to come into play in the next few
moves yeah to me Tanya at the moment it
looks like it's all about this Pawn if
Wesley can keep it alive then later on
it is actually a past one uh if this
blockade on C3 is broken then the pawn
might just March down to Victory but if
Magnus Corral this Pawn somehow and it
does look weak on a dark Square then at
least he has the safety net of going a
pawn up and I would start potentially
with it just to move Rook to C1 maybe
Rook to B1 if you want an open file the
whole idea is yes you might part with
the bishop pair but now your Pawn might
just drop on C4 another natural move to
me at least on First Sight would be to
bring the Knight forward going for this
Pawn but as you mentioned there
strategically Wesley he just has to keep
this one alive and we've been talking
about those Fisher random pieces on the
back rank the queen actually for the
first time in the game has a natural way
out off the back Rank and this Rook if
the queen moves will centralize and
there we go Magnus does show the point
behind his last move lifting The Rook up
last turn to swing his Rook across with
uh Rook to B1 there and okay open file
preventing the black queen from using
that B5 Post Yeah it feels like Magnus
he wants to develop but he's also trying
to prevent Wesley's ideas in the
meantime I like this multi-purpose move
for if you want I I think um one of the
things you have to look to do in a
position like this when you're worse
like Wesley is we keep focused on the
pawn right we call it active defense
right or you make a a defensive
sacrifice I think Wesley's ideal
scenario is that somehow he loses that c
Pawn but he gets compensation and the
reason I'm focused on that is the C4
Pawn is under Fire right by the White
Knight and that prevents Sorry by the
Black Knight that prevents white from
taking twice on C4 you lose the pawn and
if there's some world where this black
Queen can get to A4 and you can start to
get some counter play right I was even
wondering if there's an idea that you go
Rook B8 and you lose the C Pawn but in
exchange you get the B file right not
right now but I'm just I'm pointing out
that especially when you're about to be
under two minutes and you don't want to
be just grinded down in a worse position
that you have to look for active chances
right you have to look for an
opportunity to uh to make it tricky and
so sometimes you look to give up your
biggest weakness on the board and if
your opponent takes it prematurely you
end up getting some form of counter
player compensation they didn't see
coming now unfortunately Magnus has been
called the mini carp off right karpov
was famous again for never taking your
weaknesses until you were begging him to
right because he just really the boa
constrictor we talked about right so I
don't think Magnus is going to fall for
that but I still think that the
Practical idea of Wesley looking to get
some chances on the D file against that
E4 Pawn maybe Queen A4 these are the
moves we have to look for and
I guess he's going to win a pawn this
way because the pawn on A6 but I was
thinking this it does look a bit strange
doesn't it to grab this one uh you know
maybe it works though because if it does
work maybe it just wins the pawn I think
if you take it if you I guess we have to
go back to the analysis if you take
twice and play Knight takes E4 there's
also Knight E5 right away which is part
of the problem is you just instantly now
that I'm seeing it you attack the queen
in the night but okay let's stay with
this because Magnus won the pawn and
maybe black please oh wait it's
happening fix it and if white does jump
with the Knight black will be forced to
bring up the queen uh to D5 offer a
trade defend the Knight Will Magnus get
greedy with the a pawn pick that up
immediately or jump in with the Knight
what would be your choice here David
I would at first calculate this night
jump just because the potential rewards
the potential profit is you might win a
piece what you might uh immediately
Force black into an awkward pin but if
this doesn't work out you'll move there
Tanya defending everything here Queen D5
then I might switch to uh just grabbing
the pawn Being Greedy at least putting
something in the bank for later I think
that's how players calculated the top
level in this position white has two
very tempting moves Queen takes Pawn
you're a safe Pawn up the game goes on
or there's something even more direct
even more ambitious and forcing and
that's where the players start their
calculations so I think Magnus is
looking at 95 if he finds nothing else
then he'll take the pawn and the game
will go on it's funny though because
even though Magnus went for this and and
we'll assume that it'll work because
he's he's the greatest chess player of
all time I do think Wesley is breathing
a little bit of a sire relief here
because we now have a new Dynamic on the
board which is the opposite code Bishops
right
um and if you can get a blockade you can
hold positions where you're down
sometimes even two pawns with an
obstacle of Bishop banking so obviously
that a pawn is going to be a problem and
when you have a bishop on a long
diagonal with an a pawn running it's not
your favorite position at the same time
I'm I don't think it's over yet for
Wesleyan what a hold this would be if if
Magnus doesn't win this game that's a
huge win for Wesley yeah it's not over
yet but again it comes down to that 17th
piece as well right obviously with just
a minute and a half on the clock Simon
how much of a challenge is it not just
having a minute and a half in this
complicated position but playing Magnus
with that amount of time in this
position but it's hard enough just
having a minute and a half at any stage
in in your life especially as you get
older like me uh but it's it's It's
Tricky but I I mean there are I don't
know I was just thinking like stats wise
what are the chances that Wesley's gonna
hold this uh I think it's a two result
game I don't think he can win so uh will
he hold this or will he lose and I'm
thinking probably better chances he's
going to draw this that's uh that's what
I would uh go for because the opposite
color Bishops and um okay we're going to
see a forced variation here uh actually
this is quite interesting because um now
uh Magnus not grabbing that pawn not
trying to exchange Queens but keeping
pieces on the board and keeping more
pressure but it's uh I don't know it's
it seems like Wesley is still okay just
about hasn't got much worse for him
which is good because pieces are coming
off the board but he has to move quickly
which is also not good well you say when
you're okay Magnus has been great Magnus
clearly brought some prep to the table
we'll find out if it was from the world
championship but when you're a player
like Wesley you've been here before
you've run up against Great prep and
you've been down on on the clock before
so you have to keep your wits about you
and if all you can do is hold but you
manage to do so you put this match on a
great trajectory because holding with
black already is a good result holding
with black when you were maybe much
worse and up against World Championship
prep if that if that's the case would be
again just a psychologically uh massive
win for Wesley now there's there's Rook
A8 is there Queen takes D4 I don't know
but even if even if black loses the E6
Pawn if you manage to get the a-pawn you
have really great drawing chances in Ops
Code Bishop end game and so Wesley is
looking up we have a move on the live
board that doesn't look like it's good
it looked like your move Danny's so
natural bring your room to A8 just kick
the queen away win the pawn behind it
but he takes a timeout Wesley G6 that is
slow it smell of something dodgy here it
feels like you give white an extra move
and the evaluation bar confirms this
what is the punishment I think I think
that's just nerves I mean we it also
weakens the black king I know the black
king gets an escape square but it's so
slow in a position like this
Tanya we see there the engine
suggestions yeah I was
always jump into the game
became your own King
and with the seventh rank open uh David
this could end badly very soon for
Wesley very quickly we see the engine
gives this almost plus six for white and
you're hitting a bishop I think it's
just the fact that black isn't ready to
deal with the pressure for example here
I'm just going to take off this Knight
just to get rid of any potential tricks
and I'm already seeing night jumps maybe
into D7 I'm seeing whoa is this queen oh
it's nearly trapped I was gonna say I
think I trapped it but the black queen
can run out to A8 but then E6 has just
came over
completely game over why why did he play
G6 let's go back I mean I was literally
just talking about Rook Aid and the
drawing chance has increased and I'm
mind blown here like what did he moved
on here I mean he must have seen a ghost
yeah Rook A8 was phenomenal I mean let's
put it on the board the instead of G6
David the engines had it like the most
logical thing to do was to put the Rook
on A8
and to win the A2 Pawn
what did he see where is the ghost that
he saw here like was it Queen B7 maybe
it's Queen
possibly uh I mean queen B7 hits the
bishop so maybe he was but even if you
just move it somewhere yeah well there's
queen of seven checks so I get a little
nervous but this is what he was scared
of some uh some checks here but either
way it feels like he needed to just
evict this queen it's so powerful as we
were saying in this variation and all
variations this Pawn is just going to
drop off and uh now just to show the
computer thinks that white is winning
after three different moves we've seen
this one Rook B7 super powerful
Conquering the seventh rank Seventh
Heaven There For The Rook uh also the
computer thinks simply pushing the pawn
is strong and uh also a night jump which
is quite tempting hitting this loose
piece I mean Rook B7 seems so natural
and it was actually a Checkmate in that
last line you showed David which is
quite nice
um just to show some dangers in this
position so you attack the bishop if the
bishop moves you come to D7 and um I
think the queen only has one square and
um or maybe it's not chip mate but it's
very close you take on E6 and then after
the king moves well you have many ways
to win a lot of material I I forgot the
F Pawn was there I was thinking Knight
take GC Knight F7 is good enough though
yeah Knight F7 just wins immediately and
you're picking up everything uh there's
there's no counter play for black as
well black needs a couple of moves to to
to gain any kind of counter play in this
position so if Rook B7 is played I I
just don't see how Wesley has any chance
of surviving and Magnus doing the right
thing here he's played very quickly but
he he smells that there's something here
he's he realizes that G6 is a very
nervous move and he's now spending that
time and this is what you should do in
chess you should make sure in critical
moments you tank some time that's what
your time's for and you only get maybe
let's say three or four critical moments
in one game of chess and he's doing
precisely the right thing here just
finding the the way to proceed I'd be
amazed if he doesn't play Rook B7 I mean
it's it is so normal to play Such movie
attack Rook to the seventh rank but the
good news for Magnus is it's not the
only move that keeps a big advantage in
the position whatever he does he needs
to take a decision quickly he's under
two minutes now so the clock Advantage
is uh dwindling away there Magnus having
a big thing will he find the critical
move that gives him a big advantage or
the other moves that we see on our
screen that still keep majority of it
and it goes for one that doesn't he
plays Rook B5 oh my gosh is he back in
Wesley so
matters calculate now wow is there a
floor to this though suddenly black is
thrusting a nasty check made in two
blacks Queen is attacking the F2 Pawn
Magnus is leaning in maybe messed this
up maybe surprised by something at the
end of this line meaning it now suggests
that uh
doesn't have any more follow-ups right
he doesn't have he doesn't have another
move here and black is spreading to take
F2 I mean that is amazing actually I
mean like this was not a very long
combination and he's now tanking time
maybe he just didn't consider this move
Pawn takes maybe he just thought Pawn
takes doesn't work and Wesley so now has
many Perpetual check ideas uh with this
queen and his Queen and Brooke are very
active uh you you can't take the bishop
in order to win uh this is quite
remarkable and if Wesley holds this game
well you're gonna have to say that he's
he's gonna be favorite because it's a
complete Houdini act to to say this one
and this check the king just moves and
Magnus reacts there he knows that he's
messed up a big Advantage David did he
miss this resource of black just
stepping up with the King yeah I'm not
sure what is Miss Tanya but it's
something big because this position
looks totally healthy for black Magnus
now he needs to pull the brake there we
go it's forcing the Queens off the board
but I think what he might have missed as
well is that black can block this check
with his bishop and suddenly Black's
pieces are active and yeah Magnus is so
strange he he sensed the moment he knew
there was something direct but he tried
to force it in the wrong way and yeah we
rarely see him blunder like this like
this now he's just got to go into
reverse gear get the Queen's off and
bail out with a draw I I really can't
understand how huge this is of Wesley
soholes yeah not only drawing with black
but again he was under immense pressure
preparation down almost nine minutes on
the clock at one point has been living
under the two minute marker here for for
quite a while so again it's not over yet
but if Wesley so holds this game we say
grab your popcorn yesterday buckle up
everyone welcome to the weekend because
it might be starting with a bang yes
it's like what Wesley said Wesley in the
interview said yesterday well look
Magnus is a brilliant play one of the
best players but he's human he is human
and he makes mistakes he's not a robot
he's not a computer and Wesley now
activating his Rook aiming at that pawn
and if he can win that pawn and I'm I I
think he might do even if you get free
pawns versus two on the king side an
extra Pawn for white it should be a draw
with accurate play but saying that you
are playing the best end game player of
all time so a bit of work to do still in
this position to to uh oh hello
ending is lost and that is it Wesley
resigns after saving a difficult
position Magnus Carlsen takes the lead
in their grand final first set what a
comeback water game twists and turns and
Wesley they are reacting to that Miss he
knew he had the draw in his hands wow
what in the world did we just watch what
a wild turn of events again you're
heartbroken for Wesley because after
fighting so hard
and he'd earned the draw he ends up
giving it to Magnus who he can't believe
it either he's he's shaking his head and
disbelief unbelievable I mean I think
Wesley just realized that he only had
one second left yeah they had to make it
as simple as that it was that piece that
Tanya keeps putting out the clock and I
think that was just the one thing and he
just had to make a move and he just
forgot about the clock I that that was
the only explanation for playing that
that losing move there oh and you saw
the Magnus Carlton also in disbelief and
what just happened there in the end what
a roller coaster game there David what
happened yeah yeah so many twists and
turns in the space of just the last few
moves we saw Magnus build up a winning
Advantage with some phenomenal opening
preparation Wesley fighting to stay in
the game and he was gifted an
opportunity this position once the
Queens came off should objectively lead
to a draw Black's best move maybe is to
just move this bishop Wesley ran out of
time here before he could do that uh he
could for example put the bishop on F6
there's pressure against the A2 Pawn yes
you might have to defend a sad end game
a pawn down but you have great chances
Black's Bishop a very strong piece with
pawns on both sides of the board instead
Wesley panicked here with one second
left and he played the horrible blunder
King to F7 was it a mouse lip did he
intend to go to F6 maybe a better square
but uh this was elementary Magnus just
lines up here the rook and the bishop
and the King all on the seventh rank now
this is a simple pin and a simple winner
David I want to stay in your analysis
here we got permission here before we go
to college if you back up to the
position of Rook B7 I've been sitting
here analyzing it and trying to figure
it out I want to show brilliance by
Wesley cell real quick if you go back to
before Rook B7 in that critical moment I
want to show why Magnus didn't play Rook
B7 because at the end of the line I
think we were suffering thinking this
was easier than it was but a rook B7 the
line was going to be Queen takes D4 and
after Queen takes E6 check the point is
that after the king moves you're
threatening F2 this was the we were
making it sound like it was easy so
Bishop takes E4 but on F takes E4 it's
actually not so simple here and I think
Magnus was just stuck in this position
because look it gets worse after Knight
F7 check King G7 the only move that wins
here for white is Queen E5 check taking
the Queens off the board if you take the
bishop white black has a draw with Queen
D1 and queen of three
and again I think we were we were
sitting here looking at Rook B7 thinking
it was easier than it was but actually
Wesley resourcefully defended this game
brilliantly and then Magnus couldn't see
the end of this line because if we show
again how hard was Queen E5 anyway so I
just want to show that we just saw a
master class game by two of the best
you're ever gonna see do it and Magnus
stole one Magnus Carlsen was dominating
the game for the most part of it Wesley
with his resourcefulness managed to
equalize but in the end the blunder cost
him the game and Magnus Carlsen takes
the lead Wesley has to strike back we
will be back with more Grand Final
action in just a few
foreign
[Music]
to me
basically it's a tool for improving your
chess game it gives you tailored lessons
for different phases of the game and it
seems like a very useful tool so again
better than players around your ratings
it looks like you get a really nice
overview over over your games and what
you need to focus on and what you are
good good enough at
you have all my weaknesses black on
white on paper is devastating and
interesting and fun at the same time the
middle games are a really rough and
aimchester said it to me again so and
that is definitely the most popular move
there today I actually learned a few
tricks and everything that I love to
play
one of the basic things you need to
improve on and also Advanced plays it's
very detailed at getting straight in
working out if you're opening his work
or your tactics and giving you some
personalized lessons so it's pretty
broad pretty much everyone
and aim chess was great at finding out
that most nearly everyone we had their
endings were actually very bad so they
need to work on yeah work on that area
of the game to be honest I think aim
stress can help everyone it's helped me
especially approve in the opening
realize my strengths and weaknesses
there and in the end game where actually
I thought I was very good but it pointed
out areas that I could work on if you
want to improve on anything from start
and opening to end games
any level can do aim tracks I suppose
[Music]
you can get stronger faster with aim
chess analytics and lessons there and
you get your first one free with the
code CCT
go.chess.com aim chess what around one
we had Getty in division one what did
you make of that Tanya I thought that
the worst was passed for VAs Lisa and
then he lost at that second it was it
was a bit painful to see how he lost in
the end and he was surviving so long uh
off to game that Magnus put up it was
amazing it was amazing and it was an
amazing battle and catty with the
players fighting for that qualifying
spot at the end of the season there are
players fighting for a lot in division
two as well that's right Tanya and I'm
so happy that those are two very young
just players Dennis last a week only 17
years old same seven and 22 years old
Tanya we were talking about this much
yesterday tennis last a big one in the
Armageddon we have stem down in the
losers bracket but Sam won the lizard's
packet and went all the way up and he's
in the final and today their first game
was very interesting and then lazovic
had a slightly better position in the
end but it was not enough for him to
convert and now they are playing the
second game
has us on the edge of our seats and for
these two youngsters Dan Laz he's just
17 years old he would be the youngest
ever participant in division one of a
CCT event if he wins today against Sam
Savion but it would also mean so much
for Sam I Am with ten thousand dollars
on the line big tour points and that big
ticket into division one of the next
event Kelly will be keeping us updated
with all the action and the exciting
battle and we also had a lot of fun and
it was a very exciting battle we will be
showing you the full video later of what
happened when Dany and Simon took to the
streets of Oslo for a chess challenge
here's a little sneak peek for what's
coming up
Simon has a distinct Advantage because
his openings are so bad they tend to get
more blunders look at this look at this
slow position which is going on over it
[Music]
three three three okay
oh that's the subtlety you didn't see at
the end of the line I'm in the lead
Simon sack your queen queen come on I'm
freaking out here where is the wind bro
there you go there's another one
pressure's on I'm playing against two
enemies here Simon Williams and the
clock
[Music]
Donnie Simon that was a lot of fun to
watch and did you guys have fun playing
against uh also
we did we had a ton of fun playing
against the entire city of Oslo who was
there
um I'm still reeling a little bit from
that match I just that's you're talking
about two of the most accurate players
of all time and uh I think it speaks
more to the complexity of that position
I think sometimes it's easy for us in
high in the moment to get caught up in
the eval bars yelling at us in hindsight
there was a lot to that game to figure
out and it led to some blunders but but
Wesley says find a blunder I mean just
shocking so and he starts with the white
pieces he has to win at least one game
to start with I have your predictions in
my hand here uh are you guys still
sticking with them or regretting them
can I have my piece of paper back please
Tanya no you can't do it
we will be revealing the predictions by
our experts later today but for now it's
all on Wesley so he starts with the
English Simon once again
just opening out there and this is very
traditional English and we saw this uh
what I remember about this position and
the world championships in I think it
was 86 and Seville casparov karpov they
played this E5 reversal sit in many
times but this is now one of the more
main lines and this Knight retreat has
become quite a trendy move I think Grizz
Chuck uh first played it uh and it's
meant to be quite a solid way for black
to to meet the English opening and I
have to say one of the things that put
me off playing the English as white was
this exact line because I didn't like I
don't like giving my opponent more space
when I got the white pieces so that's uh
that's the advantage of this setup from
the black side black has that pawn in
the center and it really is just the
reverse Sicilian
um and it's a good Dragon for white but
a good Dragon may still be a bad dragon
in some cases such a thing as a good
Dragon oh yeah maybe a bit of an
oxymoron there and uh this position but
it's pretty standard right David I mean
I'm sure you've you've played this kind
of position as well yourself yeah plenty
of times and it goes back to something
we've been talking about throughout the
week it's often players just they know
where they're comfortable in terms of
Pawn structure and Magnus uh as you say
that Simon is losing a bit of time with
black you also start with black so you
start Tempe down but despite the fact
it's kind of transposing into a sicilian
type of structure Magnus is still happy
he doesn't mind losing two or three uh
moves Tempi as long as he gets a
position that he's very comfortable in
and we see Wesley so already thinking
Magnus may be just trying to dodge some
preparation here as well getting Wesley
thinking at this early stage I must
admit I'm skeptical I like White's
chances here just feels like you're
leading in development but uh yeah that
must be I was gonna say I made that
there's no such thing as a good Dragon
joke as someone who's lost too many
games on the black side of a sicilian
Dragon to talk about but this position
is good for white I mean this position
is uh super solid because let's let's
remember that the thing that makes the
dragon bad is the Yugoslav attack right
it's the very dangerous well-prepared
Pawn structure that blows black off the
board this position is actually a very
fun one to play you've got the bishop
kind of like the Catalan Bishop David
you've got a rook coming to see one
um we'll just draw some arrows use our
coloring board here because I think yeah
the bishop develops yeah the other
Bishop you have the Rook on C1 these
positions are so easy and fun to play
for white so I'm also skeptical I like
it as a potential rebound game for
Wesley which he desperately needs so I
think he's off to a good start off to a
good thought you say that but he's just
burnt about two minutes on the clock
once again we see Magnus taking the lead
on the clock there after this last move
by Magnus Wesley taking a big thing here
this last little pawn move David is this
uh something that's new unfamiliar
territory what's going on yeah I must
admit that to me uh in this position if
we just backtrack a couple of moves I've
always played this move Knight back to
B6 it just feels like you're getting out
the way uh also a very popular move has
been developed recently bringing the
bishop out to Knight to F6 as Simon said
is trendy and here I'm just familiar
with bringing the bishop out I think
Magnus maybe again he's just trying to
get Wesley out of preparation uh H6 it's
a waiting move it's a useful move if for
example white pushes are pulling forward
it takes away this Square from uh
White's Bishop but yeah it feels like
Magnus just playing mind games here and
we should mention to the viewers okay a
couple moves have been played that uh
the dragon is signified by this bishop
coming out to G2 and just to show the
idea we call it a reverse Sicilian
because essentially uh let's backtrack
the whole way very quickly here
essentially the dragon or a very similar
let's go for the accelerated Dragon Here
for a similar position would be this one
branching from the Sicilian where here
after Bishop to G7 white could for
example bring the Knight back and we
would see something very similar to the
game just with reverse colors so white
is essentially upper Tempo and one move
in chess very important so it's always
signified by this bishop on the long
diagonal and this Pawn structure and how
tricky is that Danny to face these
reverse openings because you're familiar
with the main line but with that one
move difference one move Advantage how
does that change the Dynamics it can
change it a lot and it can also well
there's two things right sometimes it
can literally change the concrete nature
of the position and so you do have to
double check your lines you have to
calculate things to make sure you're not
walking into a blender but the other
thing it can do is change how people
feel about it which is what we're seeing
it psychologically affects them to the
point where they're using maybe three
unnecessary minutes right Wesley down on
the clock again so I wanna I wanna again
just call out that while I do like
Wesley's position I think he has a good
chance to rebound and maybe level this
thing at least as far as the first few
moves I still just you have to applaud
Magnus Carlson and reminds me of what
Fabiano caruana said about him which is
again people underestimate how well you
have to know openings to look like
you're avoiding openings and so Magnus
has a very playable position for black
playing moves that you highlighted
yourself David even in a trendy line
with Knight F6 that you've never seen H6
the bishop goes to D6 instead of E7 this
is not a typical structure for for how
black plays these reverse dragons yet
he's in a playable position and guess
what he made his opponent burn three and
a half minutes on the clock so this is
the kind of stuff he does in Rapid chess
and it often pays off
yeah I mean I think that's a good point
of making things look easy I mean you
get this not just in chess but uh the
best footballers the best musicians the
best anything and they they make
something look really simple sound
simple uh but in actual fact uh that's a
skill of someone who's an expert making
something incredibly hard seem easy and
that's what Magnus does do by playing
actually quite quite quite strange moves
I mean I think if these this is also I
think something that's uh if this was
played these moves from black like 10
years ago 15 years ago uh you you'd
probably guess that the player black was
quite a weak player because uh it looks
quite clumsy you know the the as David
said Black's night has gone to a square
it doesn't normally go to the pawn move
is it a waste of time the bishop is in
front of the queen what's it doing there
is it they're they're quite weird moves
there goes another pawn move and um it's
it's kind of yeah this is this is a
modern very modern way of facing White's
uh whites position here and yeah I I do
like white as well I mean I and white
must have a small Advantage here no more
than a small Advantage but he's got a
better Pawn structure like you get in
Sicilian he's develops his piece as the
slightly better squares and there's
generally going to be pressure on the
queen side here with that Rook move uh
against Black's Queen side yeah and uh
it does kind of reflect how Magnus works
on chess uh I I've been lucky enough to
discuss some chess stuff with him and I
know that nowadays he's much more open
with uh kind of the younger generation
he helps them as well discuss his chess
with them and I remember hearing him at
a lecture once he was comparing the
king's Indian to a line of the French
defense and he was like okay they're
exactly the same for King's Indian and
the French if the center is blocked it's
just like a mirror image and he's always
thinking okay I can play this one tempo
down and that's why sometimes he starts
the game with one eight one A3 or these
strange moves and he's literally just
comparing these openings and because he
knows all of them he can recognize
patterns and kind of draw on that and
take his opponents kind of into area
areas that and structures that he knows
better and yeah again the clock time
sits potentially relevant for later on
this position I still prefer white just
because uh you're up on kind of a
well-known opening just one tempo here
but watch out for Magnus understanding
the middle game and knowing what to do
in advance playing extremely quickly in
the next few turns getting a glimpse of
the genius of Magnus Carlton here and
his opening approach and strategy and
now once again Wesley down on the clock
also how difficult is it for Wesley from
what just happened in game one
a tough opening but he comes out of it
and he has his moment and then a one
more blunder how does that affect him
honestly I I'm still affected can we
talk about how I'm emotionally affected
by that right now I mean I feel like
chat's affected we all got a little bit
robbed after an amazing defensive
performance by Wesley so that Tenacious
D and then a blunder and I saw Greg
shahadi and Shadow so everyone just like
going nuts like
so anyway we all need to let it go and
focus on the moment including Wesley so
telling you you're right because it's so
hard when when a game ends that way you
almost would rather have just gotten
your bleep kicked in right you would
rather that happen thank you
I meant your teeth sometimes I bleep out
my teeth um the point is it's this is
really tough and Wesley really has to
just focus on the moment one game at a
time the guys who live in the top 10 in
the world have short-term memory loss by
Design they're all there because they
have the ability to focus in the moment
I believe Wesley can do it but he has to
speed up a little bit he has to speed up
a little bit and a Goldfish Memory right
now is what Wesley needs uh David what
do you think about this lost move uh by
Wesley with the Knight jumping forward
yeah Tanya I think you've called it back
to the chest at a perfect moment because
there's a positional threat on the board
and again we can draw on that pool of
knowledge we have from other openings
here the Sicilian and In the Sicilian
with reverse colors we talk about an
exchange sacrifice and it's a very
thematic one here Rook takes night
you're giving up material you're giving
up a rook five for the night three
points there but you're shattering
Black's Pawn structure and let's say
black plays a silly move puts the King
on h8 I think Wesley would just go for
this uh without too much thought you
break the black structure look at how
weak these will be long term and uh also
there might be another Pawn up for grabs
in the center and if you can get away
with this then look at the ruins of uh
Black's position here it might not be so
simple but these pawns are weak at least
this Pawn is weak long term white
tonight is going to get a nice square
and I think if this works tactically
then this is something that Magnus is
really concerned about right now a big
potential sacrifice and I think
strategically that would give white a
beautiful position something to watch
out for yeah definitely I mean there's
another threat as well David I think and
uh we mentioned that you must know your
plans in the middle game and again this
is a perfect example David straight away
knowing that this exchange sacrifice is
so important but the other plan that you
must know In the Sicilian is moving that
Knight to C5 and you get this the other
way around when you're playing sitting
but that is a key key square and this
maneuver the night well if you didn't
know about it beforehand you you might
not recognize it but when the White
Knight gets there it causes so many
problems to Black's Queen side and just
generally to Black's position and I
would say that's equally as scary that
move I mean very simple move just
improving the night pressurizing Black's
Queen side and uh if I if I was black
here I'd be I'd be very concerned
because there's a lot of positional
threats Brewing I think you're making a
really great point and the more we're
looking at now the clocks get even the
more you're starting to see what what we
were talking about earlier come come to
fruition right we applauded magnus's
practical approach we applauded the fact
that he's going to get a playable
position as Black by avoiding the main
lines but
but we also said the whole time that we
liked White's position right that we
liked the dragon structure reverse
because the thing that kills the dragon
is the Yugoslav attack Checkmate Pawn
storm if you don't know it just Google
Yugoslav attack Pawn storm the point is
right now this is not a Yugoslav attack
which means White's king is not coming
under Fire white holds all the cards on
the queen side whether it's the exchange
Sack or Knight C5 I think Wesley's in a
really great spot um to rebound here and
again that would be the drama we want so
we'll see if it's the drama we get
okay well yeah sorry David I was just
gonna say queen D7 maybe your idea on
the board timer yeah I mean at least
that stop maybe stops The Exchange
sacrifice I guess it does because you
look after your pawns but it certainly
invites the White Knight into that
square uh I mean you don't have to move
the white knight in you can do other
moves here but it's a very tempting move
to play and that like Shane sacrifice
also might still be on the cards two
very tempting options here for Wesley so
and the one he chooses will that make
his ambition clear in this position
David yeah
if Wesley so can get away with
sacrificing his Rook on this Square he
will love that but the problem is maybe
that the queen can take and yes your
knight can jump out of the way with a
double attack but once the queen moves
do you have enough you have sacrificed a
rook for just a night in porn and at
least this time Black's pawns are still
alive uh I'm struggling to see a
knockout blow here it does feel a bit
shaky Black's Queen lacking squares but
uh maybe it's Clinging On and uh the
other idea Simon you mentioned uh in
this position Knight to C5 I think
that's the more tempting of the two
right now but it's all about whether
maybe in this position black has
something I don't see it right now do
you push this Pawn do you maybe try and
trade off this beautiful Dragon Bishop
either way uh Wesley's calculating this
right now I think pushing the pawn might
be the key because you can't take F6 oh
okay I thought you can't take F6 because
white black will take F3 with tempo
right okay so that was right but I guess
you can just take E4
yeah no no maybe you just moved the
knights uh in this position for example
you come back and something like this it
looks like white Bishops just have
fantastic range instead uh Magnus has
gone for something else he didn't go for
this instead trying to trade off one of
those beautiful Bishops on G2 and yeah
sacrifices here he's backing this up
with tactics is this Pawn hanging this
is the big mystery right now we've got
to show up the dangers that exist if
white does get greedy in this position
yeah I'm trying to work out this uh he's
gonna say I'm sitting here surprised to
see Bishop H3 because I can't make sense
of this position but it looks like 95 in
the end there's a capture on G2 and a
check on D5 that's it right okay yeah so
rookie five will just show it trade
trade Bishop G2 and then Queen D5 okay
so that's the
yeah yeah and taking with the bishop I
guess the fact that these pieces are
hanging in the air uh there might be
some tactic here maybe it's just B6
kicking away this rook and same tactic
as Danny showed I mean I was going to
say this is why he's the world champion
he's not but he kind of is the best
player I mean he he spots these just uh
little tactics to get out of trouble I
mean uh I think the first player first
world champion I can remember he did
this very regularly was aliakin alakine
uh he used his tactic and uh you want to
do these positional things on the board
and you have to use tactics to sometimes
get your positional desires on the board
and this is a perfect example of that I
probably wouldn't have seen Bishop H3 I
probably would have just been I lose a
pawn here and I would have gone very
passive uh had I seen the tactics I'd
love to play this move get rid of
White's great Bishop open up the rook
and it's these little things which might
save the game right
um and that is a nice tactic it's so
easy to miss as well right really easy
to miss Magnus with his incredible
ability to piece up all of my new
details in the position strategic ideas
with a tactical offense on the board to
keep pieces defended makes him one of
the greatest players of all times and I
want our body language expert to step in
right now Magnus with folded arms what
does that tell us about what's going on
on the board well generally when you
lean back in life I'm assuming I'm still
the body expert really back can you like
relax a little bit and you know your
arms are not crossed that'd be a bit too
defensive he's just covering his face
like this very relaxed look at that head
to the side especially when you go to
the right hand side you're recalling the
good moments in your life and when you
have the pineapple hair as well it gives
you that radar to pick up certain
positive things I'm really glad you
brought that up because we have not
talked we have not talked literally
enough about magnus's hair can we just I
like it can we talk about that for a
second I mean it just reminds me of a
cool pineapple but it is it it's it's
cool right I mean I like it I like the
long hair what do you reckon Dave uh no
comment on the hair no comment okay air
quality but the hair quality today
wow well no one can talk enough about
magnus's hair but I want to get back to
the position because the part on E5 has
been decking and it feels like LPD or
loose pieces drop off so many tactics
what's going going on here yeah
sacrifice one word for Wesley so right
now he's given up material yes he
grabbed a pawn but he's actually the one
going down in a minute because White's
rook and White's Bishop in the center
both attacked simultaneously he has to
give up some material now it's just how
to do it he he he shook his head while
we were distracted
um when he went for it now he does
choose to sack The Exchange membership
C7 he could have also played Rook takes
C6
right yeah which was the type of
exchange sacrifice we were talking about
earlier I don't know if we want to
analyze that because I'm curious why he
went for that instead of Brook takes C6
um there's a fork as David is
highlighting but if you take
whether you take or even keep the dark
Square Bishop I felt like this was a
little more of the traditional type of
exchange sack you can see meaning back
up the bishop on the diagonal at the
same time I mean the eval says for a
reason black would have a small Edge but
these positions are full of long-term
compensation
um I'm just it's curious to me that he
took on C7 giving up the Rook on C5
because he didn't make Black's Pawn
structure any worse if we look at the
live game here box pulling structure is
totally fine here maybe he's banking on
the fact that uh kind of opposed to that
previous variation at least he's got a
passport because he's not running yeah
that's fair and the D6 square is
available
for the for the bishop of the night long
term the Magnus doesn't go for it
for it that he hits the bishop on C7
yeah just uh kicking this bishop out no
matter where the bishop Retreats I think
next move he'll potentially go for it
unless he keeps kind of playing tickle
with this bishop and kind of keeps
attacking it with his Rook or his Queen
uh interesting once they could sack The
Exchange now yeah you can take this
piece of sugar four
anyone's game
anyone's game and that that's what
Wesley needs right I mean he has to win
he has to win one of these three games I
mean it's so he's got to take risks
before the show we were saying Wesley's
a bit of verse for taking risks and I
think in this game he's doing the right
thing right I mean he's uh he's been
brave he's got to be brave he bit his
weird he's being brave and he was
shaking his head I I wondered if he was
shaking his head in hindsight based on
the movie plate or the fact that he took
so much time to do it because he's still
down four minutes on the clock and
sometimes the player is shaking their
head and we think it's because of the
last move and he and they're like yo bro
you gotta move faster just like wake up
you know shaking their own head side I
don't know I mean I think the position
is objectively playable I love the past
D Pawn as you highlighted David there's
compensation here for Wesley I think
it's a lovely position for white I mean
I know the evaluation Bar says equal but
again if we if we just forget about the
evaluation bar or even just bear it in
mind and think who's got the easier
moves to play this is such a big
question in chess is it me or is it my
opponent is it white is it black well
White pushes Derek pushes Derek the D
Pawn all the way all the way to Derek
it's not it's not Daryl it's not a dog
or Danny David
that's a thing it can be Derek but and
other days we will go David or uh Daniel
a few once so I mean I saw a comment by
chat that Wesley's losing because of his
time management and as much as chat
knows I love disagreeing with them I I
agree I think that even with magnus's
great prep in the last game ultimately
what happened Wesley held and then he
blundered because he almost ran out of
time in this game he's got a good
position
but he's down almost four minutes on the
clock so it's rapid for a reason let's
do the math here black has got an extra
rook and white which is worth Five
Points white has got a minor piece for
three points and two pawns so it's sort
of an imbalance but still balanced in a
way we see the bar somewhat level and I
want to get your opinion would you like
this position would you like to play
this position as black or white are we
voting yes we are okay everyone write
down your answers no I'm kidding
um I think everyone's just going to say
white I would rather play White I think
I think it's you can't say black in this
position yeah it's just 100 yeah I think
oh look I think it's 50 50 eval by the
engine for a reason I mean let's let
David speak for himself white okay
maybe you were black
oh this is tough but you know what I
might have that bias of who is playing
black but I get it that white just feels
like you've got easier play a clear plan
ahead and in these time formats it's all
about how easy it is that you can make
fast moves in the position the plan that
you've been highlighting with the Deep
on moving forward makes so much sense
right now and with black not having
enough pieces to really build an attack
against white skiing so many trades have
happened it looks like Wesley is the one
who's got that slight Edge right now but
with the clock sticking low it's a game
for all three results and maybe the
least likely of them it is it is a game
for all three results you highlight the
clock the 17th piece and of course
they're both going to be under five
minutes here soon but I want to
highlight for those who might prefer The
Rook so that they don't feel bad out
there even if we all chose it I think
there's a reason you could do that
because look objectively The Rook was
given the value of five versus three for
the minor pieces for a reason because as
the board opens up the Rooks have more
more pure power right they can control
more squares and at some point if white
isn't accurate when the time scramble
ensues those Rooks are going to get
going right the open files will will be
available
and was that a mistake by Wesley sorry
Danny yeah no no it's okay and and uh
and anyway so it's the Rooks are there
for a reason I think Wesley just wants
to really protect C5 with D4 next yeah
and at first thought I thought okay
White's Bishop is lacking squares maybe
it's something to do with that that the
evaluation bar reacted there but White's
Bishop does have a nice Outpost a nice
perch to sit on on D6 protected by a
pawn
confusing to me I think for both the
players neither of them will regard this
as a mistake even if objectively there
is something in the position and for
Magnus that would have been an expected
move he looks uh yeah looks like he's
struggling to come up with a plan as
black
okay you see it bring it down I think
it's G5 for black
just jump in and show it goes to D6 you
can play B6
okay undermine The Bishop's protection I
have no idea yeah but I'm like what why
did the engine okay I'm wrong B I
thought okay I thought this was maybe
the idea like what is the unique reason
why E3 suddenly gives black an edge it
turns out that the computer thinks this
is fine I guess why I could just play D4
okay I'm wrong I was just guessing okay
trying to trying to figure out but 97
instead doesn't do any better yeah maybe
the idea is now this Pawn is attacked
and for example if I just defend it your
same idea Danny maybe but uh firstly do
we push the pawn and then okay
evaluation Bar says no uh this bishop is
running out of squares maybe you go the
other way uh the other natural move here
would be to plant the knights in the
center and uh this bishop yeah still a
bit loose and suddenly if you look at
White's position it's all about the dark
squares horn chain here on the dark
squares uh maybe the lights Quest just
slightly tender I'm changing my mind
guys I think I might go with lack
it's still tense though I've got to say
to a human it's not obvious at all no
maybe is just in the balance I mean the
computer's always right isn't it I mean
at the end of the day I I was just
assuming White's position so much easier
to play but now now that that night's
getting a bit funky and it is getting a
little bit funky isn't it it's dancing
around creating some problems it's uh
it's it's not clear at all uh and this
move okay well you attack the queen you
might try to re-route the Knight to B3
over to the queen side kind of makes
some sense uh to to do this an ideal
Square for that night could be like A5
in some situations C4 D6 would be lovely
but black gets the moves as well and how
do you defend C5 now the bishop comes in
you stop Knight F5 yeah it's it's very
very tense
I was coming back to it and I think it's
yeah it's a nice idea and but we've
sorry
Magnus just played yeah temporary peace
sacrifice Magnus gave up the Black
Knight but just by capturing pawns he
was attacking there just temporarily
White Knight and White's Bishop at the
same time and white couldn't save them
both and uh here we see still the same
material and balance at night and two
pawns for a rook but Danny called it the
lines have opened up the position is
exploding and for Rooks that is a good
sign whitesnite looks nice and pretty in
the center but Black's Rooks have access
it's technology General but Wesley
didn't have to part ways with the bishop
let's back up like you could have moved
the bishop and given up the Knight I
wonder if that's what the computer
wanted to do instead of Bishop takes C5
after the temporary peace sacrifice it's
kind of funny because there was
there was something to this position
that but but maybe it's not possible to
save this bishop it's maybe really
clever by Magnus he forced white to give
up this piece rather than the knights
here you want a bishop maybe uh on in
the center for example because pawns are
on both sides of the board the bishop
with the long range but you can't save
this piece anyway so he thought he had
to give it up for the pawn and yeah
let's just check out this position
Magnus is giving up a third Pawn okay
it's just been captured he's going for
checkmate he's going to try and break
through on the backpack
I like it and also that H Pawn I mean
it's very natural to use the H Pawn in
these positions where white has moved to
the dark squares fianchetto but lost the
fiend Chateau Bishop that is often a
very good way to attack and uh heating
up though because obviously whites have
porn up right white has the extra Pawn
that white knight beautiful piece uh I
guess I mean you can't move it it seems
like a nice piece but I'm also thinking
you know maybe maybe you need that to
come back to defend in some cases I've
got to ask what is the answer to this it
looks terrifying here for Wesley so
suddenly his Rook is going to be traded
and his King is going to be naked just
forced around the board maybe and it's
on the board we're going to find out
maybe that night you mentioned has to
jump back to take control of that back
rank C1 square 90 do it but that runs
into a nasty check David yeah you're
right uh this track Tanya in the corner
I I think I think one of the key ideas
though is that black isn't actually
threading anything in the current
position like you can move the queen to
B5 try try to offer a clean trip maybe
A4 okay that doesn't work yeah maybe A4
okay yeah my point is like black takes
F1 you take and you check the king's
gonna run to E2 and we're getting out if
you made a mistake oh I don't know Queen
H1 looks scary oh no maybe yeah you go
to E4 he's gone with Harry the H1 and
uncharacteristically turns out to be a
bad move what uncharacteristically of
Harry the computer's just gone Haywire
how can H4 ever be a bad move well
there's got to be some nasty tactics
here isn't that I mean the first four I
was thinking is that you can you can
take the rook and just go for checkmate
but maybe maybe there's something
stronger Magnus is Magnus has that look
of like wait a second yeah he's seen
something here right but can't you just
take the Rook bring the other one down
put the queen in the corner I guess
there's something wrong with after it
for it Simon Just fret and check mate
yeah I mean that that that would be you
should I mean you should always look for
the most forcing moves right and you
should always look for the captures and
you should also look at ways you can
create Frets and yeah so you just take
and then Rook C1 simple threaten Queen
D1 Checkmate what's funny in the end of
that line is that the rook and the queen
guard always counter play there's no
Queen A8 or queen C8 so there might be
something else because the computer
doesn't like this but I would be scared
here definitely if I was white check
this out I've cheated I would have
resigned here as a player but actually
didn't check the computer apparently
white just steps forward and starts
running it's so calm so calm oh my words
how can you do that I mean that is
computer chess isn't it David look at
what Magnus just played he didn't play
the best movie it's a good move we
should mention I think this showed up as
one of the top moves but uh yeah just to
highlight here Magnus could have won on
the spot I think the idea was actually
just this check on H5 I think this would
have been a really nasty blow and if
you're for example forced to push your
Pawn this white king now is pretty much
trapped and uh any check on the second
rank I'm not sure how you get there
maybe you go back and uh threaten
Checkmate this looks like it would have
been decisive but Magnus not going for
the Brute Force approach instead just
shuffling his King we call this a very
high class move just uh preempting any
checks from the White Queen he's just
waiting yes yeah maybe Mr smaller I like
that move though because again he didn't
see this check and then Queen H5 check
but this is a high class waiting move
right you avoid your opponents
checking chances right you're really
putting Wesley so in a tough spot by the
way with only a minute and 20 seconds
left because now how do you deal with
the threats right and we see he couldn't
do it accurately he plays Queen A4 which
helps Flex Advantage increase a little
bit
and now we see the evaluation from the
engine there's only one winning move
everything is actually almost level
according to the computer there critical
moment for Magnus Carlson here he has to
find The Rook trade the only move and
the follow-up that's the most important
thing if he doesn't find the follow-up
he might choose an alternative and that
would just destroy his entire advantage
in the position he's touching the two
minute Mark David do you see the
Finishing Line after The Rook trade
don't see it yet Magnus doesn't see it
yet for sure the best move okay he's
played it I was gonna say the best move
is also the most natural move but you
called it Tania the follow-up is the key
often players don't blunder because of
the first move it's always the final
follow-up and still winning position
here is it a check with that black queen
do you dive in now maybe it's more
effective now with White Queen unable to
check the black king he doesn't dive in
you're already assignment I mean this is
the simple way isn't it I mean uh
because I mean the white king just looks
you know even if white can defend this
somehow which I don't think he can now
you've got two major pieces big pieces
the biggest pieces attacking a naked
King and it's not good to be a naked
King you can get arrested and get in
trouble
you get stories written about the
Emperors yeah clothes and that kind of
thing I throw through Prince Charles
well not Prince King Charles will try
this but like no no but yeah it's it's
just too exposed isn't it this King I I
feel and uh you're gonna have to maybe
can you play this E4 move again he
doesn't play he's trying to bring his
pieces back but it's funny though
because I still don't see the mate Simon
and one of the funny things about this
is the queen and night are really pesky
and I just want to highlight that while
E4 maybe didn't work there if if black
misses up just one move that white king
is going to run into the middle of the
board and he already has a Defender
waiting for him the Knight is so pesky
when it comes to eliminating the
opponent's check so this is this is an
eval bar for for Magnus to take but I
feel like the position is more complex
than that just then that does credit
right I feel like this is a little bit
harder for magnets to convert than first
because I mean find The Knockout Bluff
like I don't have an engine in front of
me like where's Black's when you've only
got one minute 30 even if you're Magnus
Carlson to find The Knockout blow here I
agree it's not it's not that simple I
mean you've got many moves which you
have this is where calculation is so
important this is why you train the
puzzle Rush this is why you train your
puzzles so you can work these things out
uh quickly because you do you check with
the rook and you I think this is the
right way of doing it because you forced
the king into a more exposed situation
now I'm thinking do you bring the queen
over but you have to calculate this
right David I mean uh okay wow by the
way he's giving up the F7 Pawn but it
would be made if you go for it uh we can
show that if we want because it's Queen
C1 first and then Queen D1 you have to
keep the king in the cage is that just
the end Queens Queen C1 and queen D1 is
it is that literally just as simple as
that Rook B1 there's no move oh wait
that was it because yeah I didn't
realize you can't play Queen C2 because
he wants me I think it's just as simple
as that Wesley's shaking his head and
that's it that's gonna resign yeah and
Magnus wins this he takes a two-point
lead he'll need a draw to become
champion of the aim chess rapid and it
looks like the only good move that
Wesley has here is hit the button just
resign I think he he has to resign and
it's just the Magna show today isn't it
seven seconds would you fight on would
you give up the queen for the rook and
try and set up a fortress with the King
Knights and porn he's gonna love me and
that's it wow Magnus Carlson with the
black pieces Deliver Us Checkmate and
takes his
second win and there he is what a
performance he's had today in his Grand
Final this guy is Unstoppable
he really is and I think Wesley has been
close in a couple of these games but you
see him shaking his head knows that he's
not as sharp as he needs to be if he's
going to take down the world number one
so unfortunate for Wesley it's a tough
spot to be in there despite how great
those trophies look and uh his back is
against the wall
yeah his back against the wall but
Wesley so is a fighter he's in a must
Ang situation in the next round a draw
would mean Magnus wins the whole thing
and so far it's been a Magnus Carlsen
show what was the big moment in this one
David for me it was when Magnus found a
way to activate his Rooks the position
was imbalanced we were actually praising
White's position we thought great
chances but this little sequence opened
up lines and allowed set up the winning
tactic it was here with white Bishop
looking mightily strong Magnus first
undermined its protection this poor now
kicked away from the defense of this
bishop here Wesley decided okay I've got
to move it I've got to take this Knight
and now a really clever move by Magnus
not the automatic recapture the most
natural move instead the sneaky Pawn
takes porn this bishop is trapped anyway
and uh this Knight is now attacked and
this is how Black's Rooks got active
suddenly this Rook on an open Line
backed up with the stacked up Rooks here
and penetration along the back rank this
was the beginning of the end and in
Practical terms even if there was a
defense for Wesley it was just too much
the white king as we saw was pushed to
the center and then eventually
checkmated
and delivering that checkmate with the
queen and the Rook at the end of the
game a masterpiece there by Magnus
Carlsen which gives him a second win in
the match once again game three Wesley
has to win or the aim trust rapid comes
to an end with Magnus Carlton as
Champion we will be back with the
crucial very important game three in
just a few
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
has to find a way to put Magnus Carlsen
on the spot in this upcoming game
meanwhile Dany you've been put Ting a
lot of the locals in Oslo on the spot
I have and it's appropriate that we've
been talking about magnus's hair today
because some of the answers to the next
interview that I gave with with the
awesome strangers on the street
directly called out some some things
about magnus's hair and the choice that
I gave them between Magnus Carlson or
Peter nortog
if I say Magnus Carlson do you know who
I'm talking about is that the Norwegian
chess player he's the Norwegian chess
player if it was Peter nortuck or Magnus
Carlson who would you go with I don't
know who the other person
okay that I guess that answers the
question Magnus you win on that one if
you had a chance to date Peter nortog or
Magnus Carlson who would it be
minus Magnus two for Magnus zero for
Peter take that Peter we're coming for
you who do you think is a more eligible
bachelor Magnus Carlson or Peter nortok
uh definitely Magnus okay agreed who's a
more eligible bachelor who would you
rather date if you were into that Peter
nortog or bangus Carlson oh yeah that's
a difficult question typical question
blonde dark
uh smart even smarter
um Peter maybe oh man it's okay Peter
gets one thank you damn it Magnus
Carlson or Peter nortuck who would you
rather hang out with
Magnus Carlson okay ma'am if you had to
date Magnus Carlson or Peter nortog who
would you rather date
[Music]
Wilson or Peter nortok Magnus boom take
that Peter okay that was amazing if you
had a chance to hang out with Magnus
Carlson or Peter nortog who would it be
I don't know who the second person is so
Magnus
Magnus wins again they're trying to lead
you back to chess here if I say Magnus
Carlson
uh
I don't know who he's you know who
Magnus Carlson is okay he's a
professional footballer one of the most
well-known in Norway okay okay so Magnus
Carlson the professional footballer if
uh you had a chance to date Magnus
Carlson or Peter Norton who would it be
000.
there we go
I think that answered all the questions
we need Magnus Carlson wins the battle
Magnus Carlson there the Starboy of Oslo
that was a clean sweep I have to say
that just because there is movie Magic
involved in all the editing I want
people to know that it literally was
that much of a landslide so I'm not
trying to call out Peter or anything I
don't think we cut a single one of the
questions do you know what you where you
went wrong Danny what you should have
said Magnus or me and then it's not even
close no Magnus Magnus takes the day and
it shows that his his celebrity is still
high despite no longer being world
champion here in Oslo despite the
pineapple on his head despite the
pineapple I said that was the one thing
we cut there was someone there was
someone who directly called out his hair
and was like ah I would date Magnus but
he needs to get control of the hair and
the beard remember yeah it happened she
said it so we I guess we cut that one so
there you go Magnus
and he has been having a go today on the
chessboard as well takes that two-point
lead against Wesley so in the Grand
Final Wesley so has his task cut up he
needs to win the next game it's a must
win situation for him he's a big fighter
and he has Robert Hess on what makes
Wesley one of the strongest players on
the planet
[Applause]
if you're in a must win situation you do
not want to face Wesley so one of the
most precise players in chess history he
makes very few mistakes and when he has
an advantage he does not let a slip out
of his grasp just as Magnus Carlson in
the 2019 Fisher random World
Championship Wesley so dominated his
final match against Magnus Carlsen very
one-side Affair that showcased how
strong Wesley can be when he's at his
best back towards standard chess he
plays a healthy dose of one E4 in fact
he made a chessable course over 50 hours
worth of material on the Move E4 and all
the ins and outs of the positions he
likes while Wesley so may be one of the
most precise players it does not mean
he's unafraid to take risks in this 2016
Blitz game against another than Gary
Kasparov Wesley he sacrificed the pawn
he's a lead in development and he played
the spry B4 move giving up another Pawn
because after C takes B4 he made his
Rook to C1 a pin along the C file and
after black developed with Knight to E7
Queen B3 the attack rage on and Wesley
won a very nice game so he is showing
that he's unafraid to enter tactical
territory if the position calls for it
[Music]
one of the most precise players Wesley
so there but he is having a tough run
today in the Grand Final and take a look
at that just some of his biggest
achievements he is the three-time U.S
Champion an Olympic medalist he is the
chess.com Global champion from 2022 and
Danny that was a fantastic convincing
dominating performance by Wesley yeah it
was a super hard event too I think
people forget it was a 64 player
knockout and people were going home all
the time and he made it all the way to
the end was the last man standing so
yeah Wesley great also the 2019 Fisher
random world champion where he beat
Magnus Carlson but uh he doesn't seem to
be great today
and he's in a must win game three right
now Simon against the goat Magnus
Carlsen in percentage terms how much
would you give that to Wesley
to win the next game it's gonna be
really tight I mean he's got the black
pieces
10 uh I I mean he's he's also going to
be affected by the first two games he
kind of uh knows he has to win two games
in a row and then win the Armageddon
he's gonna win three games effectively
and you're playing the best player in
the world he's beating you down you're
not on form you can't yeah everything's
going a bit funny today isn't it to be
honest and uh it's it's tough I mean but
we we must give credit to to Magnus
right I mean we're talking about Wesley
Wesley's a fantastic player but Magnus I
mean
Danny do you have some Intel on that
because he seems like he just has come
uh I don't know like super fresh and
just dominating this much his his cardio
was great David do you want to talk
about it
um no comment Danny no comment uh yeah
no uh Magnus is good at a lot of things
and we we had fun this morning playing
some paddle uh for the for the first
time in my life and being magnus's
teammate when you're learning a new
sport let me just say it's a little hard
because he can be harsh on you when
you're when you make some mistake no but
it was actually really great and a lot
of fun and David was there too yeah
Danny and Magnus beat me and ask Gilbert
uh so great warm-up apparently and here
we see Wesley getting ready I will say
he does have history in some of those
finals we talked about in the Champions
chess tour back in 2021 he did win a
couple of games in a row against Magnus
he won one of those finals when he was
behind he can also maybe take
inspiration from Abdul sator of nearly
dating Magnus in one of those games when
Magnus was already two points up and
relaxed too early but with black that's
the big challenge E4 on the board and
Wesley any predictions how do we think
he's going to open he can't go for his
usual solid stuff
yeah I mean this is this is a tough
thing and we saw earlier on the
competition that Fabiano had exactly the
same problem he paused after E4 and it's
funny to see that Magnus plays E4 when
he's happy with the draw you know this
is how things have changed maybe in the
last century of Chess uh he plays other
openings he really wants to push but E4
he's safe this is probably the best
option the Sicilian you can often get a
double-edged move but maybe Magnus will
close things down now either with a
check or by playing possibly C3 here
there's many ways you include you can
close it down here
um but I think sicilian's the best the
best pun sorry Tonya go ahead I was
gonna actually throw this to you Danny
that this opening approach by Simon is
that more because of the math situation
than anything else I think for sure and
and I think Simon Says
did you compare me to Wesley though
oh my words that is amazing I think the
opening comments by Simon and the
opening approach by Wesley are uh are
both both Justified and both because of
the match situation and I'm actually a
little surprised to see Magnus go for
the open Sicilian but not them when I
see A4 right what a choice against the
nidorf either A4 or G3 are the moves
that a night or flare doesn't want to
see and this is going to actually turn
into a positional game here
um because usually A4 is followed by the
G3 variations we'll see if Magnus goes
for it this is going to be a hard one
for Wesley to get those very Dynamic
fighting positions you're used to seeing
in the night or so um okay but uh good
choice and let's see how Magnus responds
to 96. yeah interesting decision uh
Danny I would have put all my money
there
or rosalimo yeah yeah just seeing Magnus
I mean we go back to the world
championship against Anand Magnus just
needed a draw to clinch it he played
Bishop B5 check he knows so much about
those openings how to lock it down in
every for every variation as Simon
pointed out but this one even if it's
strategic even it's more even if it's
more positional than most night off
which has uh kind of characterized by
attacking play here I think at least
there'll be life left
but do you think it's also because
Magnus he knows that he's in this
powerful form right now and that gives
him the confidence to have that little
extra fun we've seen him always wanting
to have chess wanting to have the games
go on so even though he had that option
to shut down the opening this is just
Magnus having fun
uh we saw it by his pose there still in
his his sports gear he's been having fun
all day and
um yeah it did nearly backfire I
mentioned that gamer gets up to satorov
where Magnus was really out of shape
after winning the first two games just
needing a draw somehow he could never
kind of find his rhythm and uh okay
saved by a miracle that one but if the
trend continues today we could still see
her come back I mean you can relax a
little bit too much can't you I mean
it's one of the biggest sins I think in
chess to do like you know a lot of
players when they get a good position
they're like okay I've done the hard
work and they relax and you know they
lose their concentration and it's the
same in a match situation I mean Magnus
is thinking only need a draw now and
even though he's you know the world
champion one of the biggest fighters
ever he can still relax a little bit
here and uh I think there's some
positive things about this position it's
a very uh Dynamic Pawn structure Black's
got more Pawns in the center of the
board that generally means he's got a
favorable positional Edge so a lot can
happen here so it's certainly going to
be exciting whatever the result
yeah and uh Wesley pausing this isn't
his you his uh usual repertoire we
should mention yeah it's true very
rarely plays the Sicilian night off so
we will see him again just like the
previous two games that narrative will
continue he will be the slower of the
two you imagine then in these uh early
stages but flexible for black I like
Black's position here still plenty of
play ahead all the pieces on the board
apart from one set of knights
yeah we'll see we'll see I'm trying to
be optimistic I want more chests today
you got to be optimistic but I'll be
honest again like I'm replaying the day
here and I'm looking at Wesley once
again getting down on the clock and and
you're just you're just your heart goes
out to him given I really want to go
back to that game one he defended so
well he earned that half Point hold
which was going to put the match on a
completely different trajectory the
momentum would have been it's like a
sliding doors moment in the Multiverse
right and that blunder yeah
has not been recovered from I'm not I'm
nothing's right in these match formats
if we think about the 2021 World
Championship it took one game game six
for Yan to fall apart and here we see
Wesley everything under control in that
game do you think it all comes down to
that moment the way the March has
progressed Wesley blundering in that
last uh last move losing that game which
is why we're seeing the outcome that we
are
easy to say in hindsight but I think
it's just been the general pattern it's
just the fact that he's been lower on
the clock it's been a bunch of things
magnus's openings seem to be kind of
better studied here more well honed it's
a variety of factors which have added up
to that blunder in game one but yeah
it's hard to say Simon any optimism here
um not really no no I've got to be
honest I mean I I I think uh it's it's
going to be very hard for Wesley I mean
just also again just the way the match
is gone I think that first game was key
uh I mean it's an interesting position
so you know let's not give up hope
um but I mean maybe it's a personal
thing I prefer white in these positions
because white gets the easier attack
um when black castles whites Bishop is
beautifully pointing towards uh the
black king over there and this this
could this is always something that
black has to worry about but when I say
no hope it's only because the way the
match has gone it's actually a very
interesting and dynamic position so uh
from that side there's there's still
white here but again it's just Magnus
it's just been on such great form yes I
mean like his openings have been really
really amazing and there's just been
some little moves he's done which I
don't think other players would have
played I loved his King H7 in that last
game just a little just you know just
some real subtleties which it's just you
know it's quite hard to even pick up on
these subtleties but that has just uh
put him in a class of his own so far
Magnus has not lost a chess game in
quite a while by the way he went nine
out of nine on the day one of the
Blitzen Zagreb when six of nine I don't
think he lost that day I think he drew a
few I think he did uh lose to First oh
okay cool
okay never mind I mean this tournament
has he lost it this time he has not lost
rapid and he's made it look easy hasn't
gone to a single Armageddon either so
the players have really been struggling
against Magnus in this one
strongest player on the planet currently
and he is making it very tough for
Wesley so in this match Wesley goes with
the castle there is tension in the
center and whenever this happens for
white hair you've got to decide what you
really want to do with that do you want
to trade push the pawn or just keep the
tension how would you approach this
position can I just suggest one crazy
idea because you know I I really want to
give up my bishop and I want to swing it
around and uh you know I mean this I
think this is the first thing you should
look at right this E5 move because you
force the Knight to move the Knight has
to go somewhere passive and of course
you must look at the attacking moves so
I'm just wondering if it's playable I
don't think it is if I take on H7 bring
my queen in and try to swing The Rook
around and uh the evaluation bar which
he's saying you're an idiot Simon don't
even think about it what are you doing
it's a good idea but I think black and
play F5 maybe F6 and in both cases he
gets out yeah maybe G6 is yeah yeah it's
uh just the first thing I guess you
should be looking at just to demonstrate
some of the attacking ideas that white
has because obviously if the Rook comes
here it can get a little bit scary
you're in this position but these Frets
are just lingering there at least and
you calculate them okay they don't work
some ideas are meant to be booked out
and that's right I'm not actually gone
for it that's that's right I've been
trying to I've been trying to teach you
this for so long
Danny gives me these little life lessons
all the time I try to learn but they
don't always say obviously I'm totally
kidding but it's a great you're making a
great point that you have to have those
types of ideas first and foremost on
your brain because if you don't you
might miss them and you don't want to
miss the opportunity to cash in and
those things can lead to the most
devastating attacks but that said you
also have to always calculate attacks
and sacrifices assuming they don't work
you have to look for your opponent's
defense rather than looking to kind of
make them work right yeah I mean I think
this is the first thing you should look
at yeah but you have to calculate it you
can't I mean so many players have played
that hopefully I wouldn't without
thinking and if you see a defense you
look at something else but it's a
critical idea and it just shows you that
that black king it is always a Target
right to that that kind of idea even
Rook A4 is the kind of stupid move I'd
be looking at here but no I actually I
love that I always said bleep an idea
and but then anybody yelled at me
because she doesn't bleep things out but
I actually love that idea and as much as
we're having fun here you're totally
right and honestly whether the idea of
sacrificing right now works or not you
have to have it on your brain because
one little detail changes yeah right and
it actually might work so you always
have to be calculating that and your
Rook A4 move I have a prediction that
Simon looked to do a crystal ball there
I think at some point in this game if
this turns into attack we might see that
move that brick coming around yeah I
mean it's just dangerous of Blackness
David I mean which I mean would you be
happy being black here in this position
I would be have you been black if that
uh Central tension that Tanya alluded to
if it does get clarified if for example
white stepped forward in the sense and
blocked it up too early and nothing
happened on the king side let's assume
black doesn't get checkmated then
suddenly Black's Pawns in the center and
queen side could start rolling but yeah
as long as this Central tension remains
I think it favors white this position
and that's purely because I'm looking at
Black's light squared Bishop it's never
getting out of the pawn chain there it
moves but it's still blocked and unless
white allows this bishop to come out
somehow then I think Magnus very
comfortable and I would just keep this
tension as long as possible for white
just maybe bring out the White Queen now
decide what to do with that Rook later
either to A4 or swing it across the D1
and yeah yeah just sit on this position
it's hard to come up with active plans
for black I mean you can even bring the
queen to H3 and just line that up that's
another very common uh theme in this
type of position and and actually other
you spoke about Magnus kind of using uh
the same idea in totally different
openings it's saying you're doing like
the London system it's something you're
doing like uh the the little D4 but
maybe that's another idea here put the
queen on H3 with a big fret many many
ideas
that white can play should we have a
vote who's who would you prefer here
which position I mean I think it's
because it's gonna be white it's clearly
yeah I mean I I love attacking White's
the only side with the attack and chance
Black's got to get the counter-attacking
chances 100 white for me yeah
story the story black has potential
though I mean
white should sit on the tension because
you don't want to play E5 or take on D5
unless there's some sort of you know
real thing you're cashing in on but but
black is also going to play D4 and C5 if
you give them the opportunity and uh
open up that Bishop on B7 I think the
biggest problem is that
even if you even if you play D4 and C5
it actually doesn't take away White's
chances of getting this E5 idea the Z5
attacking idea by the way I wonder if
the move is going to be
oh sorry was the move going to be
something like 984 there but that's
usually another plan to watch out for
maybe to come around this way and go
that way
and go to C4 very nice on a beautiful
Outpost here yeah 94 would have hung the
A5 Pawn I assume yeah it's like you say
Donnie just the problem is black can
advance but you're only leaving
weaknesses behind in this night if it
jumps in beautiful uh just to show
Simon's idea as well let's say black
plays a couple of moves at the very
least you can park your queen in H3 kind
of line up and yeah again if black is
careless and does nothing move then just
to show this tactic suddenly the Knight
is kicked away and they're attacking
ideas on both sides of the board just
feels like you're stuck I love this move
personally yeah I love queen of three
it's a great move Simon I think David
said it first and it makes a lot of
sense but I I will always claim David
in my world you said it first so you're
thinking the right way I think yeah
that's it you're going the right way but
yeah I mean uh it's it makes a lot of
sense and and as you say the other route
can just come into the middle good good
coordination with White's pieces and um
it's it's it's got it's difficult isn't
it for black because Black's got to sit
there and kind of wait I mean can black
push those pawns I'd love to push the
the C Pawn or something to try and try
and create some chances over there
otherwise I'm very passive as black here
yeah Magnus for the first time really in
the match is significantly behind on the
clock four minutes down now it feels
like maybe the pressure of finding a
plan of doing something with white is
getting to him often these positions I
mean we see so many ideas for white but
that can be a mixed blessing suddenly
he's kind of looking okay I can go on
the attack maybe now I sacrifice a
bishop he might be calculating one of
these long lines but uh yeah burning a
lot of time in the process first time
today all day Magnus is the one who's
behind on the clock and he decides to
take a decision in the center which sort
of makes his intentions clear when you
push that deep on blocking it down
you're looking for the attack you're
going for your opponent's king and there
we have it a rook lift you were talking
about the queen side Rook moving forward
same idea uh Sai here by Magnus but he
chooses the king side Dragon neither are
real threats on the H line I'm sitting
here like scary wow he just went for
that with E5 and rookie three Magnus
only needing a draw might be going for a
3-0 sweep he might be but I David maybe
this is also a good moment to just pull
up an analysis board because that last
move by Magnus it did allow a trick by
black why does that not work
oh yes uh let's just go back a couple of
moves let's rewind it took me a while
because there are so many tricks here uh
Tanya to realize which one you mean uh
here after rookie three I'm guessing you
mean D4 yes double attack forking the
knight in The Rook yeah and here Simon I
think uh would have been a profit if
this had happened Bishop takes Pawn now
would have lured the black king out into
the open now you give it a check and uh
I think this time it might be different
because for example after a move like F6
Simon I was just going to say thanks
guys for trying to make me look good you
know it happens occasionally but yeah um
this it's just horrible isn't it here I
mean yeah I was gonna say Magnus could
firstly the evaluation Bar says winning
but I don't see the win I was just going
to point out a draw is enough for you so
maybe you can just come back yeah and
win the match anyway punch the match the
black king I don't think can hide if you
block then this is going to end in
disaster uh with a check and a pin and
all these tactics just freestyling some
moves here but this type of thing would
have been in the air
and uh yeah let's catch up with the
current position I mean I love what's
going on here it's a great position I
think there's a threat of a draw here
with Rook H7 right yeah this is like if
C5 which obviously Wesley will see yeah
you you can take on H7 and this this
should force a draw maybe this is why
Magnus went Fricks he sort of yeah let's
show the whole thing because sure even
on King G7 you can play Queen H6 and
Bishop takes G6 and just like that you
have to capture to avoid Checkmate which
leads to a Perpetual so I I'm really
glad you pointed that out because
there's the meta within the game here
right not only is white putting pressure
and launching a potentially very
dangerous attack but also threatening to
end the game immediately the peaceful
way and then the match
in the match yeah
so big threat on the board that might
not win on the spot but gets the job
done for Magnus Carlson Wesley so has to
uh find a way to not let that happen and
David is there an easy out for uh Wesley
Hill yeah I think Wesley saved me that I
think black's only move to avoid that
trick that Simon mentioned was to push
his F Pawn anything else else would have
just been too dangerous and after this
on passant move capturing Black's f porn
as if it just moved once uh yeah
suddenly big decision for Wesley again
maybe still the same tactic in the air
in some lines there is but let's also
not uh not Overlook the fact that
magnus's plan was very committal
I mean we love we love it when we see
attacking ideas we all do not just Simon
we all love seeing attacking ideas but
at the same time The Rook is on H3
out of Play The Rook on A1 is stuck to
the A5 Pawn the bishop on F4 is targeted
and by the way black has a big Center
here and Wesley so knows how to use the
center I'm actually sitting here like
look the game is played for a reason if
the match was over we would literally
all you know be somewhere else right now
um so I'm I'm uh I'm a little excited
about the potential of this game
becoming a three result position and at
least at least giving Wesley a chance I
totally agree I mean uh actually the
position is extremely double-edged now I
mean uh Magnus has a lot of pieces
around Black's King but there's no
obvious way to break through uh black
can always go Knight f8 there can't be a
mate but black center is is has got
tremendous potential I mean if those
Pawns in the sense get going black or
easily uh take over the position and get
the advantage I mean it's very complex
David but even E5 here is is something
that must be calculated I assume
um yeah I mean what's happening here
yeah on the board Simon and this one's
heating up
wow things are getting chaotic on the
board here Wesley saw creating his
chances and it is a big chance in
division two for Dan Laz and Sam savian
to play with the big boys with these
guys in the next Champions Chester event
and we've got Ketty with us with an
update from the match in division two
that's right Sonia so far the match
between Dennis and Sam is so balanced
that there is no favorite so far they
played three games and all of them are
draw like equal positions all the time
and to be honest I see this match going
to the Armageddon one more time and
waiting for that moment to happen
and Katie if this was to go into the
Armageddon who do you hold as a favorite
there uh talking uh just thinking what
happened yesterday Danny slazovic won
the match with the black pieces I think
Dennis might be a slight favorite in our
marketing game
it is a close fight in division two with
so much on the line for these two
youngsters Dennis Again Sam Savion what
would it mean uh to these prodigies to
make it to division one be huge right
because if they have a chance to go to
Toronto it's more than likely coming
with a win at one of these events right
one of these major events on the tour I
don't think they're getting in Via Grand
Prix points and so they're fighting
right now for the next the next huge
opportunity in their career and uh I'm
excited for either one of those guys to
have a chance Sam Savio was with us in
Toronto for the global Championship so
he might come back and loss of it
getting a chance would be amazing we
will check in with Kathy on that match
as there's so much on the line so much
at stake for Dan Laz and Sam I am but
right now also a lot on the line for
Wesley so David we've had a reaction to
Wesley's last move how are we assessing
what's going on on the board yeah
suddenly the evaluation bar drops and I
think we this is reflected in what we
were discussing Black's pawns are
rolling in White's attack while looking
from promising hasn't actually
materialized into anything tangible and
are those pawns just rolling feels like
uh yeah momentum black now when when
Magnus first played Rook E3 I kind of I
wasn't I kind of did this it obviously
went for a position where we saw these
chances for a sacrifice in a Perpetual
but I was surprised not because it was a
bad move I was surprised because it was
probably the most committal way to play
the position Magnus look at his pieces
Rook Queen Bishop they're all they're
all in literally on the king side and by
the way the eval bar is going the other
way so this is we talked about how he
got a little bit nervous Magnus himself
said in the interview after beating
noterbeck that he fell asleep at the
wheel in game three versus DOTA bit
remember and then he kind of got lucky
because the youngster got a little
nervous and blew the Rook ending but
Magnus admitted he lost his focus in
that third game you hope it's not
happening to him now because Wesley with
a win and momentum might be a little
more dangerous than notorbeck 100 I mean
uh that that Center's coming through
isn't it and I think there's one just
really key move here this looks like a
safer option to play first but if if
black can ever play E4 blacks Black's
gonna take over this game yeah I mean
white must sacrifice on that square I
feel uh uh but this is a very nice move
as well because you're lying up against
the queen and the rook and uh White's
pieces might just start going to pass
the squares and uh I think I think
there's a Wesley's got a fantastic
chance to win this one yeah the best
chance he's had so far yeah suddenly
this Rook which looked like it was doing
some great work it wishes it was
anywhere but this Square you have to
evacuate your queen and your Rook from
this diagonal over the next two moves
and I just don't see a comfortable way
to do that if you move your Rook for
example the Black Knight is coming
where's this queen go I don't see any
good squares here either and like you
said Simon as soon as the queen moves
somewhere safe then these pawns are just
rolling and these pawns might just
match their way down the board winning
pieces winning material in the meantime
and by the way winning on the clock yeah
which we haven't seen before in this
match Magnus they're leading in leaning
in he is feeling the heat of the
situation it is the first time all day
when Wesley has had a good position and
that time Advantage he needs to convert
this one but there's still a lot of
chats to be played we know Magnus it's
not over till it's over he's made all
those big comebacks and for Wesley how
do you how do you assess his chances of
making this happen in this game
I actually think they're very good and
uh a single win for Wesley so is a
different Wesley so he is arguably the
most Jekyll and Hyde player of those in
the top ten because when he's on form he
is dominant and we've seen that he is
now already the first player to enter
the losers bracket in the first round
and make it all the way to the Grand
Final but when he's off for him people
remember the 2018 candidates Wesley
doesn't want us to remind him of it but
that's just an example of when the world
thought Wesley was ready he started off
poorly and he fell apart right so Wesley
is a Jekyll and Hyde type of player you
don't want him to win a single game and
now under three minutes for Magnus and
the troubles are just starting on the
board
just not his type of position Magnus
where he's all in he likes to be kind of
having an option at least to pull the
brake at some point maybe transpose into
an end game but right now it's kind of
find something now or bust it's a
horrible assignment for white yeah I
mean it's quite close I mean I you know
if I was white here I'd be trying to I
don't know if we can maybe show this but
I'll be getting quite desperate because
I I can see what's going to happen as
Dave has shown and my pieces if I start
retreating I'm probably just going to
lose this game because I'm going to get
kicked back black center is going to
come through it's so easy for black to
play so I'd be looking at like I know it
doesn't work but Knight E4 is the kind
of tactic and if you had your Bishop on
G5 here this kind of thing could work
but we'll just show this as Pawn takes
Knight and I'd want to check here and
after King h8 I'd be wanting to play
Bishop G5 you know if my Bishop was on
G5 originally and I think this was the
big mistake that Magnus played then Rook
H7 check would would be leading to
Checkmate and I think this bishop H6
move that Magnus played this is this is
just uh overly confident and
um it it basically uh has has led to a
bit of a superficial position uh because
you know Magnus it looks scary he's got
pieces there but they're going to get
kicked back none of these tactics now
quite work and uh he's had to move his
Rook to a bit of a bad Square there and
maybe the Queen's going to retreat so it
looks uh looks bad for Magnus I agree
and use the word superficial because the
pieces look
pretty but they're not doing much over
there I use the word committal right
because they're completely all in on the
king side and if you don't have if
you're not cashing in there you regret
those types of decisions so when you
when you combine superficial and
committal you get bad romantic comedies
don't do superficial and committal
together man bad rope bad rom-com do
only one
you got to do one you got to be all in
on The Superficial keep it keep it
casual or or get or commit to it oh
prediction time
uh yeah I think so yeah yes oh wow wow
will we have a match on our hands and
Magnus there looking super uneasy with
what is happening under two minutes on
the clock he's lined up the rook in the
queen on the G line right now
where does he start building his chances
to wrap this one up in game three
I think Wesley is trying to find a way
to just prevent any chance of building
uh building a comeback here for Magnus
Wesley now I think a good moment to just
invest a bit of time because the
kickback will start first Black's night
I think is going to choose a square I'm
not sure where it's going to go he's
going to jump to C5 maybe back to
retreat hit that White Queen with the uh
black light Square bishop and then the
pawns roll and uh step one will happen
the reports will continue rolling the
white Queen's gonna get kicked back
White's Rook actually looks really
clumsy blacks Rook so far as the MVP
just holding the whole King side
together normally we talk about the rule
of three white has three attacking
pieces here but can't break through that
black Rook too well placed and
I don't see how Magnus is going to do
this I think he needs a helping hand I
think he needs Wesley to go a bit wrong
in the next three or four Moves In order
to stand a chance maybe not kick back
the white pieces to the
uh kind of worst squares right now
difficult Rusty is one of the best
defenders in the world right he is also
we talk about him being a very solid
player how do you assess his skill of
being able to convert these kind of
positions I think he's also one of the
most lethal when it comes to converting
his advantages he's uh again these are
this is the type of position that is
complicated and requires a technical
finish I think he's actually very good
at similar to Fabiano in that sense that
he he tends to navigate the complexity
very well
um and uh
you know it remains to be seen but he's
also got a two minute time Advantage I
think that pressure on the clock for
Magnus combined with him just being
objectively clearly worse this makes it
very very tough for Magnus so I uh I
really like Wesley's chances here we've
seen a one move blunder unfortunately
whenever you've seen him one move
blunder already in a match you worry it
could happen again for those just
joining Wesley was in a dead equal
position drawn game in game one and lost
in one move
um so you hope that doesn't happen again
but uh but he's better here and shot's
there rooting for Wesley Simon yeah I
mean like it'd be great to get another
game yeah so get fourth game and uh also
in the fourth game Wesley will have
white let's not forget that and if
Wesley wins that one well it could be as
the start of a remarkable comeback and
uh maybe we shouldn't jump ahead quite
yet but I mean just Black's got
everything in this position right
absolutely everything White's attack is
not happening uh you can avoid any of
these threats very easily look at the
look at that Center you talk about a
good Center I mean that is overwhelming
it's just a roller a rolling Steamroller
of pawns coming through and uh I think
you know with the you know body language
we should have a look at I feel Magnus
is uh you know got that crosses chest
saying yeah I I'm I'm gonna okay you're
gonna be going to my grave here he just
needs to do the other one and uh he
realizes Magnus that he he should lose
this game uh if everything if Wesley
doesn't make a mistake we should
probably highlight that
the reason Wesley kept The Rook on the
sixth rank David if you want to analyze
real quick because I wonder if on Rook
F7 if there was a bishop takes G6 idea
more drawing chances obviously you have
to trade on on E7 first but I think that
I think that there actually was
something to that even if it's not even
if it's not a draw I think blowing open
the King was actually kind of dangerous
so maybe he or at least wants to keep an
eye on that pawn right he kept The Rook
on the sixth rank which is good
instructive chess for the viewers anyway
prophylaxis sometimes you stop your
opponent's idea before it's even a
reality so whether that sack was going
to happen or not I think he wants to
keep his eye on it Simon maybe uh your
prediction will come true Knight A4 on
the board if we see a trade on A4 guess
what's gonna happen Rook A4 Danny you
called it you said maybe it would happen
as well well it's a little different
than we thought yeah yeah this one
because Magnus is worse and that Center
is rolling but uh but yeah I mean you've
got nothing to lose as white now you
you'd love to throw the other Rook over
and just kind of cross your fingers and
hope that something lands basically I
mean if you get your Rook there actually
you know it's another attacking piece
and the Queen's coming in so it's not
it's not too shabby then and uh you know
this exchange of dark Square Bishops
um it might help white a little bit
because the queen can safely come in but
that Center is scary really really scary
and maybe black just re-roots his Knight
into the central or something now starts
attacking himself uh but it's not over
yeah it's certainly not over and the
time situation Wesley is I don't know is
he getting nervous this is where it gets
dangerous right I mean when he gets down
to under a minute yeah and he and he
realizes he should win but the position
is not as easy as he thinks
it can go wrong do you think there's a
psychological Factor when you're playing
against Magnus you get a better position
sometimes even a winning position and
just that makes you nervous the fact
that you you're getting close to it I
think 100 yeah it's uh though these guys
have played each other enough Right
Wesley as we saw in the stats before the
match started has racked up 19 wins and
34 draws in his time he's lost 24 times
as well but so Wesley Wesley knows what
it's like to win so I don't know that
he's totally thinking about that but I
do think he's thinking about the fact
that he's already blown a game today
right that's the problem is the most
recent memory is hard to shake off
without a rest day like you have at
other tournaments right these online
formats are so challenging to the
emotional strings of these players
because you don't get that time to take
a walk on a beach have a nice dinner
call Mom at home right that doesn't
happen in these events so I do think
he's suffering a little bit from knowing
he may not be on form today so but we'll
see but oh wait F3 what happened bad
that's a bad move never play F3 never
play a three Ben Feingold is right doing
it ruthlessly
yeah big threats White's Queen is
overworked overwhelmed blacks
threatening to actually distract her
using the Rook on the B file you can't
touch anything near the white King right
now otherwise you'll just get checkmated
you have to bring a rook back to defend
the first Rank and a pawn drops off the
board Wesley's turns his Advantage into
something maybe not the most clinical
finish there but the evaluation bar
computer making up its mind still big
Advantage black of course porn up as
well
can Magnus hold this putting the ball in
the back of that killer touch is still
difficult but he's getting closer just
magnus's position with the King Bishop
Queen Rook lined up on that first rank
it looks so dangerous for white feels
like there should be a finish at this
moment Simon any ideas and why and can
Magnus even retake that pawn
no I mean I I think he's got to try to
move his Queen in uh but I I think yeah
look look at the position the black
queens entered black is material up uh
Wesley also I like the speed he was
moving there he was playing so
confidently and now maybe the black Rook
can simply take that pawn move into the
position so this is going to be critical
but it looks like Wesley's going to get
one back here Magnus with 10 seconds
only as well uh yeah we're gonna get a
game four I'm I'm pretty sure you know
what a jinx it yeah right knock on knock
on wood but by the way E3 was just like
lights out for Wesley instead of because
E3 threatened D2 to win a piece and and
the B2 Point anyway but he should still
be good here he is now up what is it
just a Clear Pond along with um White's
King kind of being open but
I I'm almost I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
say it's over yet because I think it was
over if Wesley found E3 I don't know
that it's over yet but Magnus is back in
the drawing chances chair and he's got
four chairs he's back in the drawing
chances here he's having a poll Now
isn't it basically it's just important
it was more before and it's just a pawn
I say just to pull and that should be
enough to win but at this level but is
it going to be enough David to win I've
seen Magnus wriggle out yeah so many
times I'm I'm serious I mean we don't
maybe have time now in the analysis
because we're under a minute but E3 was
lights out if we want to quickly show it
so I'm actually I'm actually not sure
anymore at all where we're headed E3
threatened E2 and the only way to stop
losing the piece was to move the queen
and then B2 Falls so this this was like
lights out right and the computer was
okay maybe not Queen D4 there whoops
but maybe just wait for a moment just
bring it yeah Bishop of five C2 B2
everything's falling and that the point
is you didn't give up your biggest asset
which was the protected pass Pawn that
that e-pawn so this is no longer clear
at all
let's catch up this is the current
position still a pawn up for black but
if Magnus gets the Queens off somehow
chances oh the bar drops and six seconds
for Magnus five Wesley under 30 seconds
as well he has he's in a must win
situation but it's getting closer to
draw territory now yeah I mean there was
a chance missed there by Magnus but it
is getting down to a pure bullet Blitz
now and uh for the first time magnus's
King is pretty safe and he his Queen
might be able to infiltrate position The
Rook may be able to come in and it's not
easy actually this position anymore it's
just not easy for black I mean uh I
never write Magnus off as just a lesson
I've got to learn more and more in any
position you've got to learn that lesson
I should have learned it over the years
by now but okay okay this is looking
good though The Rook is now finding a
good way to improve itself you must stop
it coming to G5 and uh Wesley back on
top again it's uh that's a nice maneuver
there that Wesley's does on getting the
rook in front of the bishop so it's not
pinned it's very tense so very very
tense and is that another Pawn that's
going to drop looks like it White's H
Pawn is doomed Black's gonna go two nil
up on the king side here and okay Magnus
looking for counter chances he's going
for the black king big threat White's
Rook trying to land on the seventh rank
but Wesley Conley defends and the
problem is it's just one check okay two
checks but this one could you find Rook
H7
I could have traded off Queens Queen B6
would have forced the queen oh my gosh
you missed it and Magnus is blundered
he's gonna get checkmated here shortly
she celebrates there he wins his first
game and we've got a match on our hands
as Wesley strikes back he's done what's
in the impossible and we get a game four
wow and it's funny because in that final
moment the evil bar gave us one last
heart attack Magnus had a draw he missed
it I bet this is what David's going to
show Wesley puts the game away Magnus
not happy about that losing with white
no he's not happy he could have wrapped
it up in three months in three games and
take a look at that he does it he gets
the job done right there which means
match is still on if Wesley wins the
next game it will go into Armageddon
what a crazy fight this was David what a
crazy fight just those last few moves
alone Wesley was completely winning two
pawns up big attack for one move he let
it slip and Magnus was actually winning
and uh of course the game ended abruptly
two moves later let's show those final
stages it was here white giving a check
to the black king where Wesley did let
it slip he played the most natural move
in the position G5 we can't blame him
for this but it did open up the sixth
Rank and if Magnus had spotted the move
Queen to B6 Magnus might well have just
won the aim chess rapid Queens are
forced off the board and suddenly white
porn is going to do the business instead
however Magnus missed this opportunity
only a few seconds left on his clock he
played a slow move Rook B7 same idea but
this gives black the time to drop in a
check and magnitude simply resigned
because black has multiple winning moves
you can give a check with the black
queen you can give a check with the
black rook and white is about to get
checkmated
we love the drama I mean we you know
that was incredible I mean Wesley so
have Mission Impossible there uh I I
mean coming back to win with the black
pieces after losing two games who would
have thought that was possible I
certainly didn't think it and Magnus
just over pushing over pressing and uh
at the end I thought he was going to
come back and he missed the chance there
as well so uh what's gonna happen now I
I think I think uh well we don't know
for a reason that's why the game is
played as they say that's why they play
the game because we don't know it's a
game at the same time you got to applaud
Wesley not just because he lost those
two games the way he lost Tanya for him
to then keep his emotions keep his Focus
he's right back in it and by the way he
gets the white pieces in the next game
this is not over I wasn't just the win
it was the style of player as well by
Wesley with black there dominating that
game three let's take a look at our
score line of the Grand Final here
Magnus winning the first two games in
dominant fashion and then Wesley does
what look like the impossible Strikes
Back in game three with black he gets a
game four again in a must win situation
we will be back with the critical game
four in just a few
foreign
[Music]
the most elite bullet tournament returns
don't want to miss the fourth ever
bullet Chess Championship featuring
Magnus Carlson for the first time he'll
join reigning champ Hikaru Nakamura 2021
champion alireza ferrugia and more to
fight for their share of the 100 000
prize fund it all kicks off on July 17th
at 9am Pacific use exclamation point BCC
in chat for all the details
next Monday July 17th the bullets Chess
Championship begins where 16th of the
world's greatest speech chess players
will contend for the bullet chess Crown
will Hikaru defend his reign will feruja
block his path and take back the title
he held just two years ago and will
Magnus
bccw shake up the field entirely submit
your bullets Chess Championship bracket
now for chance to win six months of
diamond membership use comment fantasy
in the chat bracket submission close on
July 17th when game 1 of the BCC kicks
off
want to improve your game click the link
in the chess.com navigation bar to try
aim chest today and increase your rating
31 faster than standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chests your digital chess coach
[Music]
unlock your potential with the aim chess
lessons and targeted training and you
can get your first month off with the
code CCD at go.chess.com aim chess and
right now Wesley so has to unlock his
potential to win that game forward to
force an Armageddon Magnus Carlsen needs
a draw to win the whole thing big
question will Wesley so be able to do
that a question only he can answer
meanwhile Dani you've been asking some
fun questions to Oslo a lot of questions
and today we're getting into it we've
been excited for this day all week
because we get to say and share some of
the fun things we did on Saturday and uh
we we had a chance to talk to some
people passing by about what they
thought Tanya and David did because we
wanted to know how recognizable they
were as chess commentators along with
Magnus Carlson and here were some of the
answers that we got
Hey sir it's a beautiful day to ride a
bike yes I love your tattoo it's
gorgeous you know either one of these
two are for for 100 Chrome probably
actors probably actors that is right
they are actors what do they act though
action problems action that is right
that's correct that is correct oh look
you're not messing I'm totally messing
with you but you're doing great you're
doing great you're doing great
they're a couple that's right that's
right but where have you seen them it
was on a dating show which one love
Island love Island that is wrong I can't
give you two and it was Duolingo love
love love language okay if you had to
guess what they do what do you think
they do Style Style Style Style and
fashion that's true in a way yes they
are both Puma models
modeling yes that is correct they are
both models model yeah okay that's
actually incorrect they're chess players
I don't know why I didn't even think
that
okay can you if you name them I'll give
you 200 Chrome I don't
how are we gonna work this out you don't
know their name you want me to like you
yes you do okay then I like you for 200
Chrome do you know who either of these
two are you said you watched it
that's right is it like a celebrity
they're both celebrities they're both
very famous but do you know why judge
the game they judge the game that's
right there you go you win maybe your
chest how would you how did you know
that brochure she was right I gave it
away all right 200 Krone do you know who
they are yes yes you do who are they
yeah they're my friends they're your
friends from back home I think we did it
Checkmate Norway boom
we're out
that was
not just out
since we've got that
yeah
Action Hero that's my next right Action
Hero it was great honestly you should be
it was a lot of fun and we I think we
actually had a few more people recognize
them but she has commentators but we had
to get all the funny comments in so they
are very recognizable on the streets
maybe not quite as recognizable as
Magnus but who is so anyway that was a
lot of fun it was a lot of fun and David
uh there were people who said who
recognized us as commentators as well
the Champions Chester is big and Oslo
exactly actually just last night coming
back after the show I saw some guy
looking at me for a few minutes and he
just kept making eye contact after all
he was he came over he was like look I'm
watching you right now yeah it's
everywhere we love it creepy
I'm watching you
we've been having a lot of fun in Oslo
and with the action that we have in the
Grand Final as well Magnus Carlsen takes
that two-point lead Wesley saw a
striking back the first loss by Magnus
in the aim chess rapid it hasn't
happened before and Wesley so did it the
Magnus he's good and David tells us why
exactly
[Music]
Magnus Carlsen the world number one
multiple-time world champion and winner
of the previous two editions of the
Champions chess tour Magnus has played
every opening under the sun he even has
a variation of the Sicilian named after
him so after E4 C5 Magnus started
playing Knight C3 a few years ago with
the idea that he could open the center
immediately by playing D4 actually going
against conventional chess wisdom of
developing the White Queen very early
but the whole idea here is that after
the queen gets kicked away she's happy
to step back and for example if black
continues to develop normally white just
creates a fiancato gets the bishop to a
nice diagonal and later castles on the
queen side actually a very aggressive
opening not technically part of magnus's
Style magnus's real recipe for success
is that he adopts his strategy according
to the opponent he's able to do anything
with a very Universal style and if you
get him in the end game there's no
chance he's perhaps the best end game
player of all time and you can go and
check out some of his ideas some of
Source on the end game in his chessboard
courses
[Music]
Magnus Carlsen one of the greatest
players of all times and we've got some
of his highlights there I don't think
it's possible to put his profile if you
had 10 slides coming up but look at that
he is at the reigning Championship star
champion I won the 2023 air things
Masters the first event on the tour five
times three day world champion but 15
World Championships including the rapid
and Blitz championships there uh just
amazing amazing uh player all around and
he's got this Universal style of play
assignment and I know it's hard to
understand but where are his weaknesses
if any at all wow there's not many I
mean his stats speak for themselves
don't they there and um his uh his
weaknesses maybe we saw them in the last
game that he sometimes a little bit
confident a little bit over presses so
uh I mean he's really good at tactic I
mean I could list everything he's good
at but maybe it's just been a bit
overconfident at times just on occasions
that lets him down so taking risks maybe
I think Magnus himself would say that in
his older age he's become a slightly
less patient player I think in his
younger age when he was really grinding
toward those championships and winning
all those titles he described himself as
many others did as a karpovian kind of
player a boa constrictor I think he gets
a little more aggressive these days and
I think he can lose his patience a
little bit and we saw it in that game
and and you hope if you're a Magnus fan
it didn't open the door permanently for
Wesley so because we see that his stats
they're not quite Magnus stats but
they're they rival him
David yeah exactly Magnus ahead in some
of those categories but overall accuracy
extremely close uh Wesley's one of the
few who can claim an accuracy level
yeah that can match magnuses the one
thing that Wesley saw did so well in
that game three was create trouble for
Magnus right out of the opening early on
getting Magnus in these messy Waters is
that the key here David to try and get
those complicated positions as early and
quickly as possible yep that is the key
and uh Wesley he's happy to repeat the
English opening in the previous white
game he did get some chances there that
was also messy and balanced and as you
say Tanya that's exactly what he needs
to aim for uh it's first Magnus who does
switch things up no reverse Sicilian
this time black cannot play the move E5
and therefore Magnus is forced into a
different opening from here we could
still see transpositions to the Queen's
Gambit the Queen's Indian a whole bunch
of systems and okay some Mind Games
there but it does look like it's surely
going to transpose into the Queen's
Gambit uh declined if Wesley picks up
his d-pawn right now but no he plays a
very flexible line of the ratty here
definitely feels like Wesley's trying to
keep as much attention in the position
because that's what paid off in the
previous battle yeah I like this movie
free actually because uh uh he could
have played the Queen's Pawn fours
played D4 and one of the most well-known
positions you'll get in chess the main
line Queen's Gambit uh and Magnus knows
those positions incredibly well and
they're kind of like quite hard whites
find it hard to get an advantage in
those positions but this is this is a
really flexible move it's becoming a bit
more trendy nowadays and uh White keeps
that tension uh you can often get some
very aggressive ideas uh this move the
most testing move white trying to push
in the center and now we often get an
exchange and we can go into the tariffs
variation it is quite likely to see here
because black has kind of got the
positional threat of pushing the pawn in
the center one square uh further
forwards and we saw this yesterday
didn't we Wesley so I had it with black
as well in that game well this time he's
got the white pieces but you've got to
stop that black porn coming as a square
fours generally here yeah you don't want
the baloney you don't want the blown up
if black gets D4 and pushes that Knight
and then the Knight comes to C6 it's
it's a benoni I apologize for the inside
chest joke but I I wouldn't say I like
the tarash from Magnus as a structure to
go for when you only need a draw because
there's a very good chance we're going
to get a bunch of exchanges in the
center often White's best way to deal
with D4 coming is to play D4 here which
opens up the door for a whole bunch of
Pawns to be traded so and Wesley in fact
has done it so it doesn't mean that we
are in dead drawn territory by any means
the position is equal but at the same
time there's going to be a lot of
exchanges in the center and that should
help the person who's looking to
simplify matters
but the fact that Wesley gets a game
four that's already a huge achievement
given the way the day started for him
and now with the white pieces he needs
to find his chances Magnus Carlsen is
such a competitive player David you're
good friends with Magnus give us a
little insight into his mindset what's
it like when he's just lost the game
it's just win-win-win that's all he can
think about Revenge Revenge Revenge the
titles he gets motivated and he's a
perfectionist as well Danny was playing
Sport with him this morning and I think
any mistake that anyone made Magnus had
a comment so it's uh yeah it's very much
kind of I appreciate the coaching for
the record I wasn't I mean it's it's I I
was learning paddle for the first time
and I know Magnus is a super competitive
guy so the fact that we found our stride
and won some games feels good but uh
yeah he he definitely lets you know
every mistake you make
so he won who won yeah that's what we
got now Magnus and I won two out of
three sets against against David in his
in uh is Magnus a trash talker
when he wins
um
oh I don't know these days it's more
when he loses
I mean on the rare occasions then it
gets uh yeah he's quite good at winning
these days he's more modest and uh yeah
he's very grateful he knows when players
play well not that I played well in
paddle but like when his opponents play
well in chess uh he yeah he's great so
he's not just competitive over the board
it's any sport everything I found sleeps
and I think it it's true for all great
Sportsmen right
passion the interest and just the focus
on winning it shines through in anything
they do and meanwhile a trade of Pawns
and yeah I was going to say Magnus has
experience in this position I remember
he beat me in a Blitz game on chess.com
here not that long ago he beat Vincent
climber and oh I played this move Magnus
is going to push his Seaport now to C4
there we go I'm getting bad memories if
Magnus gets his Bishop up to B4 Now And
Trades off white tonight
he's got fantastic score in this
position I'm surprised Wesley's going
down this line seems like you know this
position David so you lost this position
as white against against Magnus digital
Magnus I think it was on chess.com a few
months ago
yeah there's a danger here isn't they
just uh with the pawn structure I mean
Black's got the better Pawn structure
now because that that majority of the
queen side can be really dangerous when
they start moving down the board so is
it one of those positions where white
needs to do something quite quickly like
move the Knight into the middle try to
break because if white plays too slowly
he can actually become worse here is
that is that uh
yeah I'll just show magnus's recipe for
Success here uh you're talking about
dropping the knight in the center that's
very logical and uh actually I think
that's how our game went and uh
basically what happened is that Magnus
simply took on this Square let's show a
few moves I think he captured at this
moment it might have been in a few turns
time but what he did was simply trade
off this Knight on E5 and even though
these pieces disappeared he uh was happy
to just land his Bishop on F5
controlling the open file stopping
White's Rook from accessing B1 and the
bishop always comes in The Rook always
seems to get hold of the b-file and you
know what happens next Simon yeah Harry
starts marching on the board I think he
beat you Jordan van Forrest in the last
champions tour with this exact position
you might have here I don't know if it's
Jordan B he won a very important game
there so he's happy I I he's got a lot
of experience in this which Wesley must
must know about right he must know that
this is uh something Magnus does on a
regular basis so I would have thought he
knows because he you know it's
preparation
um so I like what Wesley's done he's
prevented uh Bishop takes C3 on Black's
terms where white would have to capture
back with the seat with the B Pawn and
that structure we showed does certainly
favor black but yeah meanwhile I still
like magnus's chances very quickly I
never want a player for
instead of taking on C6 is the rest of
the Knight on F6 will move and then when
F6 comes the E3 Pawn is just too weak so
it's just a positional disaster to
commit yeah possibly uh if you could
somehow maintain the Knight on C3 I have
a feeling that Black's also going to
just dominate the evil okay and yeah
this bishop unfortunately will be left
as a bad one in this Pawn chain
inevitably too the whole point is that
black will at some point be able to kick
that knight from E5 and that E3 Pawn
will be spied on that open file so F4 is
a move that you often wish you could
take back in some of these structures in
fact you'd almost rather play for F3 and
E4 if you can get away with that even
though it's slow so this is
yeah it's interesting because everything
about this structure Simon highlighted
well if we want to highlight the three
Queen side pawns a6b7 C4 if you just
flip the board in half black is
basically just winning positionally
right you've just won with that sort of
it's a pan off bot Bennett kind of
reverse structure and unless white can
get E4 and or
undermine the D5 pawn and in a really
powerful way because if the D5 Pawn
Falls then then the whole thing might
collapse if you can't break through with
E4 or the D5 Pawn black is in a
positionally just a very boa constrictor
style position similar to magnus's style
so
yeah
um but the uh how would you define
Wesley's Style
oh man how would I Define Wesley's style
accurate I would I would use words like
technical I would use words like like
accurate
um I would say also
um
not necessarily someone who's uh
who plays slowly but he's def he's
defensive minded and that he's very he's
very forward thinking about stopping his
opponent's threats and I think when you
combine that with also being a very
accurate calculator he doesn't miss his
opportunities and he doesn't give you
many so that's the thing and so he's
ruthless when he converts and he usually
doesn't beat himself again a guy like
Magnus finds ways to win against
everybody that's why he has a plus
record against I think maybe every human
being he's ever played
um but overall Wesley is uh is actually
a tough opponent for Magnus in a lot of
ways wait you you have a plus record
against Magnus I'll tell you yeah really
but it's like it's like what you said
yesterday he said you've got to beat
them when they're young yeah yeah and I
basically beat him when he he can put
his head above the table Yeah I didn't
know that he was I think he was like
2580 when I played him uh Galveston
sometimes yeah and luckily I've never
played him again since then so I got I
got the one lucky game but he was very
young amazing yeah a little a little kid
uh still a very good little kid but he
wasn't he wasn't there yeah hardly as
strong as he is now but still I've got a
plus score
I was obviously kind of seeing it in
Jester there's probably a few other
people out there who have a plus score
against Magnus but that's phenomenal I'm
sitting next to a legend right here
that's that's you should know that by
now Danny you know but I mean I think
winning one game when he's a baby
doesn't really count but it's still nice
that's not a baby that's still a monster
on the boy well with Magnus he actually
was born 2580 that's a fun thing about
magnus's history that's it he came out
he came back plus 2500 yeah definitely
one more player comes to my mind who
might have a plus score against him in
classical I think not a back up to such
off because I think they've only played
once in tata steel earlier this year in
white and won that game
a very elite doctor Simon and I've got
to say go check out that game everyone
he pushed Harry the H Pawn it was
beautiful beautiful one you're too
modest to say it but it was a long time
ago but it was yeah I know it's
obviously nice to have that but you you
just got to beat them when they're young
this is the key and it's like all these
Indian players just try to beat them
when they're like still babies because
you won't get any chance later on their
career and by the way we've had a big
transition here we had old person which
for the chat they love that the
Ampersand lives in chat
um but if we want to back up real quick
David just to show that Wesley was not
going to let Magnus get a bind on the
queen side so we struck with B4
which which pretty much forces on the
song because you don't want that
structure to let quite get going but now
Magnus Magnus after the exchange already
goes for the king side Harry Harry is uh
he's getting involved Harry's coming
laves love it I mean this is this is the
way to do it right David I throw the
poem yeah the signal is that the white
King has no knights around no great
Defenders so this Pawn is going to act
as a battering ram might even just sit
on the H3 square and White's King side
is going to be vulnerable long term yeah
this one heating up eating up sounds
like a race with the Magna is heading
for Wesley's King but Wesley has got
weaknesses of Magnus to attack on the
queen side there who gets there first
Wesley in a must win situation and of
course there is a big battle on in
division two as well with danlas and
summer I'm fighting for that top spot
and we're checking in with Ketty who's
got an update for us
that's right Tanya we do have the final
game started Armageddon just started
Simeon wins debating with 10 seconds
only so he beat 9 minutes and 49 seconds
Las Vegas nine minutes and 59 seconds so
that means that Las Vegas is now with
white pieces in must win situation where
Serbian needs to swing or a draw to win
the second division and to get this seat
in the first division Antonio so we
haven't used big winner in the division
three You Yankee Grandmaster from China
he convincingly wins the tournament and
5 000 USA dollars wow congratulations to
you Yankee there okay I'm gonna ask you
that big Armageddon coming up with so
much on the line with these players
Dennis last winning the bid with 10
seconds how much of a psychological win
is that for him right
um well he was yesterday the one who won
the beat today he lost a bid so I think
it's a little bit pressure on him I saw
him also not leaving the chair or while
they had a break so I think they were he
was just preparing for the game it's a
lot of tension on the in this board I
can see that and I can feel that also on
the game
it is going to be a big fight in the
Armageddon Kathy do you have any
predictions of who might win division
two I have no idea Tanya I usually like
the black side in Armageddon so I would
just say maybe Savion has a good chances
but we have Dennis lazavik who had such
an incredible gay man like it's it's so
good to say so young player playing in
the first division uh for the first time
ever in the Champions Chester that's
awesome it's such a big fight between
these two prodigies and Katie thank you
for that we will check in with you on
what happened in this big Armageddon and
who books his spot into division one of
the next Champions chest Star Event
meanwhile big action year Harry the H
Pawn has arrived
all the way to H3 Harry's Gone full
Alpha zero
you go full Alpha zero all the way on H3
means that you have these long-term
mating net chances and the white king
will never be safe again after you
establish a thorn like that so anyway
but Magnus also still seems to be
playing in a bit of his comfort zone
right he doesn't have he doesn't have
time like he did in game one where he
had more time than he started with but
he's got a lot of time here David and I
don't know what you know about how
comfortable he is here you share that
you've you've lost positions like this
on the white side to him but feels like
he really has a good sense and an
understanding for the structure yeah
exactly I think we can also cut the
board in half as you did uh earlier
Danny and this time white has the
advantage on the queen side because
black has a backward Pawn on a few
things so that's the only thing I think
might make Magnus uncomfortable he
doesn't like having these long-term
structural uh deficiencies in his
positions but he does have a clear
Target the white king and he has totally
immobilized now White's light Square
Bishop in the corner we've been talking
about that piece a lot in the dragon
setups in the Catalan opening we talked
about from earlier but that white light
Square Bishop on H1 it's the only
Defender but it can never move so
despite Wesley maybe having the
advantage on the queen side his pieces
might be caught on the wrong side of the
board later I still see Magnus being
extremely happy with his chances yeah I
mean it's it's always easier to attack
your opponent's king than to attack the
queen side it's as simple as that and
it's always more fun because uh if you
if you land your attack on the king side
you Checkmate right if you land your
attack on the queen side you might win a
pawn or two but it's not the end of the
world uh I suppose the the hope is
though that Wesley can just defend and
get this pressure on the queen side you
know uh before Magnus lands a big blow
uh magnus's plan I think it's quite
simple though right he just wants to
exchange off at some point the light
Square Bishops and put his Queen on G2
Checkmate that's the kind of plan our
life just so biased for a Checkmate
attacks you just described like a
positional queenside attack like it's
like not a good idea because you just
always want to Checkmate well yeah
that's right isn't that right you you
know but isn't it more fun to attack
but you also have to be able to attack
positionally we should highlight that
the C6 Pawn is a massive positional
weakness because I think that it
actually will end up proving Simon's
point in the end but I'm looking at this
line where like we play like Knight A4
this is the most logical thing to do for
white in these positions and I assume we
get a trade on D2 and the point is I
think black's plan here is rather than
trying to defend the weakness passively
and allow white to start to get surgical
over there because the queen comes to B4
the Knight comes to C5 instead you just
go all in for this like 94 right and you
try to get an exchange of the bishop for
the night and sacrifice the pawn and
then you're going to bring the queen out
and try to Checkmate on the line squares
you know well that's why I shined that
here maybe yeah maybe David's showing it
but yeah no exactly so I think that this
is but again with best play this may not
work so my point is I'm both I'm both
validating your feelings which is what a
good partner does I'm validating you but
also sharing how I feel about the
position too okay which is that white
also has a positional attack on the
queen side can you validate back yeah
yeah white White's Stone very well some
good pressure there I I see the C6 Pawn
has gone but Checkmate ends the game
it's rule number one Checkmate ends the
game no I I am always biased from the
King side attack it's a it's a weakness
of uh of what I got I'm very interested
to move on the board but um it just uh
yeah I mean you've got to go for the C6
Pawn it's gonna be a bit of a race right
I mean if white does land on the queen
side as Danny was saying it's very
possible then uh white white could be uh
yeah doing extremely well here
race it's just a race right yeah pure
race and interesting move for Wesley in
terms of a race it doesn't look like
having a knight back on its start Square
on B1 is going to help at all obviously
the idea is to recapture uh on the D2
square with the Knight bring the white
knight slightly closer to the white king
but Magnus says no okay this time no
trade for you you can take a pawn but uh
I think this is just gonna accelerate
Black's attack I'm not sure exactly how
to do this but for example The Rook can
start coming the knight's gonna land
into the center next move
suddenly these pieces I'm looking at
them they're fast asleep and I don't
think White's got the defensive
resources here there's your random
striking again for Wesley so he loves
putting his pieces on Awkward squares so
anyway my backfire here
he plays Bishop B4 but it's already that
idea you mentioned Danny's coming in and
yeah I feel for white he's his whole
idea uh Wesley here is to bring his
Knight closer but
I'm not sure he's quick enough
big big moves ahead Magnus up on the
clock ah the pressure is on and Magnus
with the black pieces going for Wesley's
King on also in these rapid formats it's
just so difficult to defend these kind
of positions with white Wesley under six
minutes right now he hasn't taken the C6
Pawn as you were pointing out it was too
dangerous instead he moves the bishop
for creating some squares for the Knight
to come into defense
how difficult is this going to be for
Wesley when it goes down to seconds
handling this attack on the king side I
think that's a great point the
aggression against someone's King is
even more effective in fast time Patrols
as much as I'm just proving your point
over here but yeah I know playing an
aggressive position defending against an
aggressive attack is even harder when
you don't have a lot of time on the
clock so uh by the way in Bishop B4
makes it even harder to take C6 because
now Rook C8 is devastating because that
Rook on C1 isn't defended so
this is um
the eval is starting to like magnus's
position more the clock says that we
like his position so I don't see what
the best move is here for black I'm
trying to figure it out maybe it is just
94 like we've been kind of shooting for
but yeah I think Knight E4 looks very
natural I I would also make an argument
maybe for that Rook lift just bringing
black syrup to E6 just defending the C6
Pawn but I've been looking at some cool
tactics here and I think Wesley's in big
trouble if Magnus does land his Knight
24. I don't think Wesley's in time then
to bring his Knight in Magnus is
calculating that's it's
okay
he's also nursing an injury from paddle
on the right shoulder he's just gonna
hold on to it from this morning it's a
body language thing it's comforting he's
comforting himself he's regularly he
goes he's trying to steal my job the
body the body okay but he goes 94 is
there F we gotta we gotta start showing
some of this because the uh the moves on
the board are critical for the for the
story that's taking place here because
magnus's either about to launch a
devastating attack on the light squares
or Wesley's going to find a brilliant
defense and is F3 why is F3 just not
possible here it Forks the bishop and
Knight
so we should show it a double attack and
I think well you can't save both pieces
one of them will drop so I think you
have to counter attack here for example
with the black queen
it's not easy to defend this Pawn
actually not sure how to defend but if I
play like Queen D I'm just trying to
make a move that then makes you deal
with the fork now it's like Knight G3
and Rook E3 oh nice I guess okay yeah
that looks like it um from this this
bishop as soon as it gives a check it's
going to be deadly and uh suddenly the
position is falling apart you're giving
up a piece for a few pawns but white
king lacking Defenders and this one we
can calculate further it's probably what
the players are looking at this type of
thing and uh yeah F3 is the critical
move I was going to say as well you
cannot play the move Knight to D2 to
trade off this Beast because suddenly
another sacrifice I think wow and uh
here for example is there simply a check
Maybe
lovely I mean this just looks deadly
like uh I have a feeling there's gonna
be some tactics on this Square although
wow good decision big decision he's not
gone for this this is dangerous for
black the evaluation Bar says it's
winning although complicated instead
Wesley decided let's backpedal Bishop
takes Knight instead giving up that
beautiful Bishop we've been talking
about it a lot today but he's hoping
that black cannot break through on the
light squares
from is are you going to be able to stop
this idea forever for now white tonight
holding that square
feels really flimsy to me I think you're
highlighting the right point is that now
your light Square problems are forever
right when you give up the light Square
Bishop that pawn on H3 that Bishop on G4
those squares G2 and F3 they're not
going anywhere grab a Snickers we're
going to be here for a while it's very
hard for whites to get counter played
now I think uh I mean that because that
Knight really wants to do something on
the queen side I don't think you can
really move your dark Square Bishop
because Bishop A5 you know if black can
swap off his dark Square Bishop for that
Defender it's going to be horrible so
what can white actually do so it's not
just what black can do white is actually
struggling to find a plan here after you
know some Queen F6 uh move like that you
know and I I guess black can build up
somehow I'm not not sure how but you can
get all your pieces in the right area
and it just looks like something will
give at some point
and for Wesley his only hope is trying
to get those spawns on the Queen's side
the C6 weakness and the A6 weakness this
last move by Wesley also hints at a
potential Queen coming to the defense of
the light Square by falling back next to
that King but right now everything got
it Magnus cannot penetrate with that
Queen into those light squares which is
absolutely key in the position
but he needs only your draw here to win
the match yeah and he's the one who's
pushing and that's big pressure on
Wesley with three minutes on the clock
that's a great point I feel like I
almost forgot because Wesley won a game
that Magnus is still in in a half a
point territory to win the whole thing
because you're right that it kind of
adds to the point that
black can almost sit on this position
right because the White Knight can't
move or we're going to lose on the light
squares it's hard to get more pressure
against that C6 Pawn
the one other trump card is that the
queen on F1 can both defend and spy A6
so that's helpful right there's some
chances there but but yeah this looks
really really tough for Wesley how can
he create chances before he runs out of
time
and remember I mean we've been talking
about trackmate Wesley needs to win this
so even if Michael's just sits and even
if there is no breakthrough for black
it's hard to imagine any way to do
anything as you said Simon
yes he's called up and prevented
Checkmate but that's the very maximum I
think if anyone can improve their
position it's going to be black here I
mean black can sneak that dot that light
Square Bishop into D3
uh improve the Rooks uh just keep the
pressure on White's position uh what can
white do I'm just struggling
to find a plan for white uh I mean does
white have to push his King side pawns
no I can't do that I I I I can't see
anything at all that white can do here
let's say I go King h8 King G8 forever
let's just say it has you know I
literally just played that forever what
are you gonna do you know that'd be a
very funny way of just uh asking your
opponent there is like Rook C2 to double
Rooks although even if they're double
Rooks I don't know what I'm doing yeah
you've already got anything fine uh it
might be time to start looking at Wesley
wanting to push that ape on ahead you
got Harry the H1 moving maybe Wesley
goes with Harry the apron maybe maybe
Harry because that does stop this bishop
A5 idea and you can use your dark Square
Bishop that's that is a good plan yeah
definitely well well spotted there uh
Tanya on I think uh this is yeah one of
the only things I can see I think you've
got to stop the black Bishop having the
opportunity to come there uh in the
position I mean it's black here I'd be
very technically put my Bishop on G5 and
just sack it on E3 at some point you
know something like this must give
eventually I feel I'm always looking for
checkmate Simon you know who's uh you
know even if it takes 20 moves you know
how you win how you win at chess isn't
it that's that's what I thought magnets
are going into a bit of a thing I think
it's the same thing he knows he set up
this beautiful position everything looks
stunning right now right pieces at the
right place but what's next yeah and
he's also trying to find that finishing
blow Simon uh and it's not that easy to
really spot how do you improve from here
to see when the the nft as well for
willingness oh Madness or is it
just wondering yeah you're jealous Simon
yeah the positions are very interesting
and uh yeah no I I I don't have any nfts
too too complicated for me timing you
will be jealous to know that the fan who
gets the NFD also gets a VIP ticket to
Toronto very jealous of that extremely
jealous I'd love to be there I don't
Toronto and I actually you know maybe I
should start collecting these things you
know he's gone back with the Rook why
has he gone back well I think I I wanna
I wanna share this line because out of
curiosity and frustration I did the rare
thing I did I did actually turn on the
lines not just the email bar to see
because I wanted to see what could
Wesley do and if we want to go back to
that position David it actually proves
the point with rookie eight this shows
how tough White's position is because
the engine's best line here is black
plays like Queen G5
and white plays Bishop C5 and then black
plays Bishop A5 and white plays Bishop
B4 in Black can play bishop and B6 and
white has to play like the engine is
suggesting that white tried to go for a
draw right and then it says here like if
black wants to play on it can play
Bishop to d8 right there's also Queen H5
ideas that suggests which is really nice
to show because you go to you're going
to E2 to kick the queen and some mating
net ideas but the point is
the engine's best line here was to hope
that white could like repeat which isn't
even an option for Wesley so if we go
back to the live game after rookie eight
okay Magnus goes for a plan where he
does have an idea I think he wants to
play A5 at some point and kick that
Bishop maybe even A5 and A4 right to
create a new line in he's he's playing
principle of two weaknesses in the
middle game right using the queen side
and the light squares but but it just
shows you look Westfield Bishop C5 what
do you do on Bishop A5 besides go back
to B4 yeah and then if Magnus repeats
Wesley they don't repeat so I think it
was instructive yeah he's got to find
another plan and it's some amazing full
board awareness there by Magnus when he
transferred that Rook from E6 to the
other side of the board
yeah I totally agree and by the way I
don't think we're going to see anything
but Bishop B4 here by Wesley and it's
kind of funny I pulled up that engine
line because we're probably going to see
it I think Wesley's going to play Bishop
before and Magnus is going to go back to
yep here it is Magnus is going to go
back to B6 and Westy's gonna look
himself in the mirror and be like do I
want to play on or am I taking a draw
because I'm worse he has to play I mean
even if he's going to lose you might as
well lose right but you might as well go
down in in a flame of Glory then there
then just uh a wet puddle
a wet puddle I said is that like could
you like cry yourself what was that like
you crazy you know a bit wet you know
like like are you peeing yourself but
can I say that I mean what are you why
are you sitting in a web puddle I don't
get it today you know just just thinking
what part
wet puddles you know like the wet
handshake you know you must get this
when you play a game of chess it's nice
to get a firm handshake before the game
but if someone goes like that that's a
wet handshake it's wet you know it's
like give me a proper handshake don't
give me the wet fish you know like what
is that
oh
should we go back to the game yeah it's
a great time to go back in the game
because we were talking about how is
Wesley not gonna repeat but Magnus is
the one who refuses the repetition and
actually falls back with the bishop
yeah really principled he's opened up
the B file for the black Rook A5 is
coming if all the Rooks disappear white
has close to zero winning chances there
as well so yeah multiple choices here
for Magnus of course if Wesley brings
his Bishop back then we'll see that
repetition that dance of Bishops and a
draw but okay he has to drop it back to
a really ugly passive square instead
just to prevent Black start Square
Bishop from getting active and I think
Magnus is kind of bullying Wesley in a
way he's saying okay I know your best
moves are just to repeat you have to
play worst moves you're only going to
help me in your quest uh to try and win
this one
but it is impressive because he could
have played Bishop E6 and made Wesley
make a make a move that also had been
bad but like you said it was principled
he believed in his idea of relocating
The Rook to the B file and he's gonna
he's gonna show it right and he
obviously knew Wesley wouldn't repeat so
he's like I'm not even gonna play these
games I believe in my plan let's go now
you're going to get under a minute
and reaching that one minute Mark
meanwhile looking at Magnus is he
heading towards the teapot situation
the wet puddle is all coming out today
um yeah I mean it's okay here we go this
is where it could get interesting so I
think Wesley has to try something like
this which is going to create some
weaknesses that you need to plug uh
those light squares as well and the the
question is now if the bishop attacks
White's Rook can white
try to get his Queen in I think that's
what he's trying to do and that's why
Magnus moved that pawn because he didn't
want to lose that pawn and
only active thing I can see or is it G4
you're going to grab Harry poor old
Harry I mean I don't know if I believe
that either but I you know you've got to
try something you've got to try to
complicate this position and they're
both getting lower time it's gonna you
know this is getting very critical
Magnus can still make mistakes right
it's still a very tense situation here
you know we see the eval bomb we see
that black is doing great but uh yeah
anything could still happen here
and I just want to point out David with
that last move black white has created
more weaknesses on the king side so now
you say Hey you gotta see B and when I
say B I mean you have to go E4 otherwise
there was this threat of the queen
falling back with a potential double
attack on E3 and A3 and you might end up
losing one of the two pawns uh if you
get greedy so he does go with E4 but
that's playing with fire because he's
tracking the center when your king isn't
that safe Yeah the more the position
becomes open now you start looking at
that dark Square diagonal from G1 to A7
so there's new there's new ways not just
the light squares Magnus calmly Retreats
the bishop to E6 and uh
you just say come on keep pushing your
pawns and opening up new ways for me to
get at your king and Wesley's going to
oblige because he doesn't have anything
else to do
um
but yeah we're liking black chances yeah
Tanya I think your move might happen on
the board and suddenly black switches
Focus to the queen side there we go
Magnus plays it and
yeah this Pawn push has gained Wesley
space but you don't want space here it's
just left those loose squares behind an
uh ugly move Rook to A1 seeding the B
file and uh yeah this is really wow
inviting a break as well Magnus is
opening things for those Bishops
credible has it been that Magnus starts
with his King side attack putting all
his forces on the king side and then
suddenly switches to the other side of
the board and the Wesley sort of trying
to now fight the downfall on the queen
side me and Simon are playing together
now we didn't we did the king side
attack and now we're doing the
Queensland we're moving over now we're
doing it we're doing it together man I
have I did think it would be Checkmate
by now I have to say but it's okay if we
win my position away we went for the
attack and now positionally we got a
protected past everything's gonna work
out these kids yeah it works
perfect day and it still looks great for
for Magnus with that pawn but it's not
as it's not still not clear still not
100 clear and they're both now
well in time travel under a minute you
can plunder you can plunder understand I
love that move though because he's
prying again now he's back to the king
side he's playing on both sides of the
board here right he's going to force
open the diagonal I love Black's
position I think Wesley's a move away
from blundering a3s also under the under
the Gaze of the queen
uh Ben Feingold would not approve but F6
that time did look very strong it's
opened things up and wow Magnus is
forcing the Queens off not what we
expected but looks like a just a good
way to cement the advantage Black's
Central pawns are both past pawns and
once the queen disappears for white the
black Rook has got full access on the B
file also look at that white king this
is the alpha zero Style just it's not
even to Checkmate put into Blackboard on
H3 it's in order to make sure in any end
games you uh yeah you paralyze the
opponent's king really nice Magnus put
his head in hand and kind of shook but
I'm not sure why because now Wesley's
base five seconds it looks good to make
a move he trades the Queens at least not
getting checkmated now
I mean maybe not the pawn on H3 though
is still pretty dangerous so and the
central pawns let's not forget them once
they start moving and there it is
rolling and white snake can take one of
those pawns but you walk into a pin this
looks deadly blacks Rooks now we're
gonna line up like Central Pawn is going
to harass this white Rook I think black
is just about to win a piece this could
be the last few moves of the aim chess
rapid
so and he wins a piece the pawn on D3 is
gonna Queen
get up backwards the check meeting it's
on the board Simon there we go oh my God
and we have a winner hack this Carson
checkmates Wesley saw and wins the aim
chess rapid
fantastic
oh and Magnus Carlsen there with the
celebration what a finish that was and
what a performance today by Magnus in
the Grand Final yeah you know that game
three was interesting because he over
committed got a little impatient for his
own good and and gave Wesley a little
bit of Hope But ultimately when it
mattered most Magnus not only won he won
on the board with Checkmate which we
don't see every day shout out to both
players for playing it out to mate good
sportsmanship and here's the final
moment
yeah I think that was the the second
time Wesley allowed Magnus to Checkmate
him today so uh and it's always nice to
see the celebration there you can uh
yeah good stuff
he doesn't get the job done in three but
he got it
Armageddon and Magnus Carlsen continues
his
incredible incredible Farm over the last
few weeks by winning his second title of
the Champions Chester season he won the
Athens Masters and now the aim chess
rapid David you made the point that he
actually just made a whole lot of top
chess players happy with that win
because now tour points matter more than
ever which means everyone wants to play
every event from here on out because
another spot just opened up given that
he's won two events yeah important stuff
and that's why we will check in on
division two and division three but yeah
what a master class for Magnus that last
game it feels like he really upped his
level he was given a helping hand in the
opening it feels like again he was
better prepared than Wesley so he knew
all the ins and outs but the Killer
Instinct to finish that one off was uh
Majestic yeah what was the moment for
you David for me it was that Queen trade
from Magnus he learned from game three
where he actually had a fleeting
opportunity to trade queens and goat
into a winning end game but this time
Magnus did not miss that opportunity in
this position White's Queen is by far
the best piece the only active piece and
Magnus traded that one off Queen to A7
the Queens have to stay on the board uh
sorry they have to leave the board
because if for example Wesley Dodgers
then Black's Queen will simply swoop in
but instead after the queen trade
happened let's just check out the
winning moves d E4 was the Clincher
these pawns are simply too strong
they're rolling they did cost Wesley a
piece here walking into this nasty pin
on the C file and to show the final
Checkmate of this tournament after Rook
takes Knight a trade and it was all
about the back rank simply this moved
the killer coming down and trapping this
white king in the corner beautiful all
coming together all those tactics
just incredible full board awareness
thereby Magnus throughout the game start
to finish in this game four and we are
being joined by the champion of aim
chess rapid Magnus firstly
congratulations
thank you yeah I just won your second
event of the Season Magnus not just the
scoreline but how pleased are you with
the quality of your play
I don't think it was great uh today but
yeah overall it was was okay but um
um I think probably the results were a
bit better than um
uh than them I play overall
that is not a single match of yours in
this entire aim chess rapid went into uh
the Armageddon and starting from your
phenomenal run in Zagreb do you feel
that you're playing some of the best
speeches right now
not particularly no
well Magnus let me ask and and jump in
and the game can be one of momentum at
times right you maybe were struggling a
little bit Norway chess June you found
some momentum in Zagreb that seems to
have carried over but then you lost game
three which is the only game you lost
the entire event what was your mindset
going into game four was there uh was
there a focus to just dial in were you a
little nervous about having handed some
momentum to Wesley
um well I was a little bit worried
at some point in game three because he
started playing
uh he started playing really well and he
just
um outside me completely but I thought
his conversion was really was really
shaky in that game as well so uh I
thought yeah I just
played a pretty poor game and uh and uh
but I realized that he didn't he didn't
place the ball either so that gave me a
good feeling before the fourth game I
thought
um
yeah as long as I play play normally
that I should be should be fine and uh I
think this is an opening that I've got
gotten a few times actually in these
situations and uh yeah I don't know why
people go keep going for this line is
quiet because it's just
it just feels easier for for black to
play and I don't think in the last game
that he was he was ever close to to
anything
David you want to explain why people
keep going for that line yeah I
mentioned during the broadcast like this
that you beat me in this line and Blitz
uh once on chess.com so yeah as soon as
I saw the opening it looked uh it looked
like one-way traffic
yeah and uh I think that was the thing
about
uh the the third game that it was uh
really complex strategically whereas in
this uh in in in in this line it's
really like it's really really easy for
for black to to play you just push on
the um on the king side and you always
have uh have good kind of play so
it suited me for sure to get in a
position that was easy to play
my apologies there I I want to ask one
more question chess specific because we
were talking a lot in game one you were
way up on the clock had way more time
than you started with and you almost
seem to be making a point in terms of
how quickly you were blitzing out those
moves I made a note so I have to ask how
much of that was prep that maybe didn't
get used in 2021 in Dubai or is it just
that you have a lot of deep lines known
in those Catalan positions
has played this line before
uh at least in some some game as far as
I can remember
um yeah yeah it's like it was pretty
deep down down there somewhere you mean
it's it's not a very good line uh and uh
to be honest like the way
but the point is the way that he plays
it it actually makes makes a lot of
sense and uh I knew the position till
night at four but then White's already
is already better and uh I mean I messed
it up later when I started thinking of
course uh but uh that yeah that's as
good a position as you can
as you can really hope for to to get any
in any opening these days
and uh well done today Magnus um a bit
of a tricky question but I'm going to
ask you do you think you'll ever try to
be classical World chess champion again
uh with uh the current length of the
games no I don't think so
okay
and uh Magnus earlier in the studio
today we also heard that you got some
paddling with uh Danny and uh do you
enjoy that how how was it did you have
fun
yeah I had fun uh Danny was a quick
learner
and uh also I got some extra
exercise because I I had to to run and
get all the you know the balls that he
was uh that he he was not getting
because uh he's I mean he's new to the
game it made sense but I thought it made
great progress and it was it was a good
fight
I appreciate that and Magnus is a good
coach actually a lot of good tips and
he's being modest because he covered
every ball because I was totally out of
position and and Magnus is a good paddle
player Magnus I only got one more
question because you're also a good
bullet player and the next thing on our
calendar is the bullet Chess
Championship
uh that's an event that's got farrugia
and Hikaru in it are you excited for
that one
uh it's so it's all right I think if I
was playing from home I would have a
decent chance but I'm playing away and I
was testing out playing bullets from my
uh my laptop when I was in Croatia and I
was incredibly slow so I don't think
I have a chance to win but it will be
fun of course nevertheless
we're so we're so looking forward to
that one and Magnus before we let you go
it's been a couple of busy weeks and
after the Zagreb win after your title
Tuesday 11 out of 11 and now this aim
chess rapid win how do you plan to
celebrate
I don't know I mean to be honest I
didn't really feel feel the energy today
but uh
I'm happy to
to uh yeah to
finish on a high note after basically
almost four weeks of a lot of chess
uh so um there will be a celebration for
sure
all right enjoy yourself and a big
congratulations
thank you
Magnus Carlsen wins the aim chess rapid
in great style and we also have joining
us the runners-up uh Wesley so here
Wesley I'm first gonna say
congratulations on finish second on
finishing second how you feeling right
now
well devastated uh well first of all
hello Tanya good to see you guys again
and thanks for having me uh I was hoping
to put up a better fight today
but it wasn't wasn't meant to be I don't
know either I played really badly or he
just played really strongly but uh
I you know I suspect Magnus is in really
good form right now
uh I think today was my birthday
but um
yeah the games were in very good but I
was very Perth by the way he played the
last game particularly
Wesley he has been in great form but you
managed to strike back in that game
three in a very difficult position
losing the first two games and then uh
you found the best in you how did you
how did you feel about that game three
and your chances going into that final
game
well I'm very happy to at least uh get
the game to win a game
uh the problem is uh
in a match when you lose one game it's
very difficult to come back so game one
was really critical
I shouldn't have spent that much time
the opening I got some saving chances in
the end but
I blundered and it wasn't enough I think
you know losing the first game was a big
blow
and then the second game I got too
ambitious I just totally underestimated
Knight D7 grabbing the exchange
but but obviously when you lose the
first two games in the match is pretty
much
over
um
so yeah I was hoping for for a bit more
today
and uh Wesley we were sharing for you as
you made that comeback we were hoping
for more chess today but uh you
mentioned you were devastated Yeah you
mentioned you were devastated what do
you make of your chances now of getting
to the Grand Final in Toronto
well I actually don't know the standings
because I'm missing at least half of the
tournaments I think I'm missing three
out of six
so I I don't know the current standings
um
but
I I don't even know the rules to be
honest I just know eight players qualify
right we can ask Danny I mean I uh when
you when you ask Danny I asked my team I
just said hey can we get updated tour
standings in real time because I know
Wesley's gonna ask me guess what you
just did so anyway here's oh here we go
look how fast the team is look at that
so look at you Wesley after this after
this week's performance then you're in
pretty good shape because three of those
four guys in front of you already have
tickets and so good news Wesley if the
tour were to end today you would be
dancing in Toronto and I saw you in
Toronto dancing last year we had a good
time and you celebrated your birthday it
was great
yeah for sure Toronto was one of my most
favorite tournaments ever a great Hotel
great food great people meeting all the
chess.com stuff you know miss you guys
there
and uh yeah I also want my best
performance as ever so the thing is I'll
be able to play the next event
and then after that I believe there's uh
is it two more or one more after the
next event one more before for Toronto
one more
yeah so I'll miss the
I miss the event after
the next one so
you know hopefully my points are enough
I think I think I'm in pretty decent
shape because uh you got the three
winners as he said
and then we always got new people coming
in so it will delete things a little bit
and it's it's a top eight right that
qualifies the Toronto yes
yeah definitely when I go back there
hopefully I can
play better in the next tournament
or not better I mean second is very good
for me but I'll play better than today
and with Magnus winning winning his
second event it actually means three
players will qualify from the tour
standings and Wesley right now looking
good there
you know it started shaky for you this
uh aim chess rapid but you were amazing
after that winning match after match did
you enjoy uh DM chess wrap it overall
yeah for sure I I love I love playing in
these events I think
uh I'm very grateful to organizers and
the sponsors for having this also I
think the format kind of suits me a
little bit you know it's a match format
and it's a rapid time control not too
fast not too slow so I think it kind of
Suits my style
uh
uh and
and I I think after my loss in the first
game I just decided to play more relaxed
just start to play freely start to play
some simple good chess obviously it
didn't work today but yesterday it
worked well and
you know I've been playing chess.com
event since uh
2012 basically so
I've been doing a lot of practice online
have a good Mouse
so I'm pretty
I have quite a bit of experience online
and uh I especially miss playing the
rapid Chess Championship event that we
had last year where you play every
weekend basically
but
yeah I mean I
I think
you know maybe chess has become much
more different than it was a few years
ago
I say a big congratulations to Magnus
Carlton of course uh and that's a given
I don't think it's necessary to
congratulate Magnus anymore these days
but
yeah we'll see we'll see how it does and
you know I mean he's an amazing player
that's really unfortunate I wasn't able
to put up a good fight today I was
hoping for more chess you know at least
get an Armageddon so
oh I see it was awesome to watch you
play in the game chess rapid and we look
forward to seeing you in the next
Champions chess Tour event uh thank you
so much
yeah thank you so much for for having me
thank you guys bye Wesley
Wesley so finishes run us up in the aim
chess rocket Magnus Carlton is the
winner and it was a dominating
performance by Magnus overall start to
finish as they say wire to wire he led
all the way what are all the different
sports cliche ways you say that someone
was the dominant and best player in the
field well we just said all of them and
that was Magnus Carlson
well Magnus wins his second event of the
tour uh in the season and not just that
he also with this incredible performance
through starting on Monday in the
Winner's bracket taking it through till
the Grand Final stays there and then
wins in the first set he also wins the
nft trophy and you can win that too and
book your ticket a VIP uh ticket to the
season and playoff in Toronto and right
now it's time to check out the
predictions that we had earlier by our
experts it's been so long I literally
forgot what I said
but the question is do you literally not
care about this right now I I literally
don't care but I may I'm so excited to
see it all right are you guys ready for
this let's do it
okay so the first one
oh I'm wondering if this was Getty
is this one it's got to be Kitty and
Katie thought we will have a grand final
reset so Kenny got it wrong this one
Magnus taking it in the first set let's
get our other one David
what is that it's some weird pictures we
can zoom into what is going on yeah
I was drawing that's a teddy bear and
then he's put Simon as a bird
Simon Says Yes we'll have sorry Danny
says yes we will have a grand final
reset and Simon as a bird love daddy
love Daddy
it's a love note that's all it is
forever
for you cheers cheers
can I change my answer Tanya I have a
poem here that I wrote it was a bit too
late but I would love to read it out for
you wow is this oh you do have it yes
please I have a poem so roses are red
chessboards aren't blue Magnus or Wesley
I don't have a clue
oh the confliction was wrong beautiful
stuff but not as beautiful as your
prediction because you did get it wrong
another yes for the Grand Final reset
and David goes on to predict in reset
two draws and Magnus wins in an armaged
all right it did not happen and finally
what on Earth is this
oh is that my artistic side
yeah it was supposed to be a portrait of
you but actually um I think it's more
like a horror horror script there and
wow yeah my artistic side wasn't wasn't
quite on that was when Tanya was
crossing her arms because she was so mad
at us because we all refused to write
things down that was when you were mad
that was your angry pose you were
standing there and we were all revised
Hugo got it right uh there you go yeah
big no big no so yeah a really big no
and a really nice portrait of me thanks
though I love it going to get this uh
framed and we will talk more about the
final results of the aim chess rapid and
all the divisions right after this break
stay with us
[Music]
air things Masters chessable Masters
chess kit cup and now aim chest rapid
they all lead to one thing the Champions
chess tour finale the finale will be
played between December 9th and 16th in
Toronto Canada
top eight players from the season will
compete to be crowned the 2023 Champion
three spots are already taken and the
remaining five will be decided in the
upcoming tour events so follow us to see
who will join Magnus Carlsen in Canada
in December
two more events remain to decide those
eight players into the Champions chess
tour season and playoff and it all comes
down to the action in division two the
players who will qualify for the next
division one Kathy the last time we
checked in there was a big Armageddon
what happened
well we don't have winner yet in
division two because uh Savin won the
match he lost earlier and he's the he
came from the losers bracket Tanya so
Dennis lazavic has another chance and
now in the division two we have wrestled
match they're gonna play two more games
uh right now maybe they have already
started to play here we can see Dan
slazovic in his
um room he is
books at the back and a lot of medals he
has won a lot of events and we have Sam
very focused
they are playing so many games against
each other and they have played also a
project league so they know each other
so well Tanya and they are making a lot
of draws and it goes to Armageddon so
what happened in Armageddon uh Dennis
lazarik had white pieces and more time
on the clock he got a huge advantage on
the on the board he was completely
winning and then in the end game somehow
he missed his chances he then lost his
bishop and it ended up in the uh rook
and the bishop versus Rook end game and
the game was ended in 50 moves that was
the rule that the computer automatically
ends in a draw and that's why Sam
servian got that picture with black
pieces and got the right to reset the
match and now they're gonna play another
match that's insane that San Savion was
able to make those 50 moves in an
Armageddon that's incredible really
the speed house they played and the most
how they played there was amazing to
watch
incredible action there and it does
continue and what about division three
division three we have a winner I'm not
surprised that you Yankee won because he
was just dominating the whole Division
and this is I think very
um Poland but he just won he was a heavy
favorite in this division he caught uh
five thousand dollars which is really
really nice price in the third division
and yeah he's in a good shape after
Koval just like he also had very nice
tournament there he just wanted other
events congratulations to you yangi that
we're the dominating performance winning
the grand final he goes back home with
five thousand dollars and 20 tour points
and the big fight is on in division two
with so much at stake big winners all
around in the game chess rapid but right
now the big question is who won when
Dany and Simon had that Oslo chess
challenge taking on uh many Blitz Games
who won more games trash talking was
allowed take a look
Grand Master Simon Williams Ginger GM
and I are about to play a whole bunch of
chess players and in 40 minutes we're
going to see who can rack up the most
wins non-stop speed Chess Championship
style the clock is running and we're
also secretly keeping track of who is
the best trash talk but we already know
who wins that
um and so we'll we'll see if he can keep
up I'll be gentle let's go clock Stars
Simon has a distinct Advantage because
his openings are so bad they tend to get
more blunders look at this look at this
slow position which is going on over it
[Music]
three three okay I'm coming for you we
knew when he showed up in his tank top
he meant business oh come on Fight Man
[Music]
oh that's the subtlety you didn't see at
the end of the line I'm in the lead
Simon sack your queen all right come on
I'm freaking out here where is the wind
bro
there you go there's another one
pressure's on I'm playing against two
enemies here Simon Williams and the
clock the Dutch is an opening he plays
which should tell you how good it is
yeah I took his course
there you go bad idea first mistake can
I give you a little bit of rules for
trash talking yeah you can trash talk if
you're doing okay on the board yeah
you're still doing terrible on the board
but you don't really have the right to
trash at all
[Music]
this is too close to cool yeah
Jesus Christ
David this is not what we talked about
man what if I don't know man you're
doing well
ready wait he wants to draw oh I
actually missed my queen
oh no not the grind man not the grinds
the David grinds this is not fun
what is this what is this is
it you're in the fight I'm in the zone
oh here we go he's back oh my gosh I'm
falling apart here I'm messing this game
up you're messing up yeah come on man
come on it's not going good come on it's
not going good and you've got David to
come as well just to put a little bit of
pressure on just Danny we're even how's
your position looking down as soon as I
open my big mouth
[Music]
reject
s
come on come on on that horse
I got a little while all right but I
survived
all right what's the score how much time
I think it's even though no no it's not
even I think it is what's the score no
no I'm not sleeping I've been winning a
couple of games here man yeah yeah yeah
look at that way can I just get a
picture of that again one more time how
is that possible
is this what is this I have no idea
swindled me I tend to perform better on
camera that's a little known fact what
happens
if I beat David house
oh my gosh it was over and I buttered my
brother
no
huh
yes
oh my words man
[Music]
I feel like the score got away from me
how do you beat David Howell and lose
anyway
[Music]
it all comes down to Tanya
what's the king doing over there
oh
what do you want you want white or black
I don't mind Black's fine Black's fine
that's fine yeah
I'm a little
perplexed yeah so am I a little
perplexed a little
okay
um
okay I don't know about that one
I have my doubts I'm actually not sure
what happens next here no that's my
problem
here we go here we go here we go hold on
I've got more I've got more comments a
little bit scary everything is
working how did you get this going I
don't know but I'm very excited about it
this is this is nasty man
Everything feels good again
barely
[Applause]
you guys hi
dare I dare I dare how did you manage
that Daddy how much did you pay these
guys off with that's all I'm thinking
it's still not better I'm still not
bitter at all we talked about it when we
weren't on camera let's be honest what
you said like you gave that a weight man
it was in hand yeah it makes it even
worse makes even worse I I had it there
I had the win and you all just actually
you all took me down oh my God
I can't just look at one of them thank
you
now I understand this painting
why he drew this but who won the trash
talking competition that day I mean I'd
like to think I did I think it was a
clean sweep man no chance no chance
you've got to give me something come on
just uh I'll take a draw would you take
a draw I'll take a I'll take a drawing
I'll take a draw on the whole thing it
was great we'll go for a drawer there
were no drugs to do here on the board
with the clicking sweet but Magnus
Carlton in the game just rapid he always
stayed in the Winner's bracket and let's
take a look at the door standings with
just two events remaining and Magnus
Carlsen at the top of the leaderboard
he's already punched his ticket to the
season and playoff Fabiano caruana in
second place very important for him to
keep that up because three places so far
will be decided on tour standings and we
see NADA back up to satro of
karunakamura and Wesley so the
runners-up of the aim chess rapid and
Danny with the finish line inside the
door points are getting super critical
super critical especially because
there's
there's a few players all within what is
it it looks like 15 points right if you
go from aronian to fetusao to Jordan Fun
Forest it's it's it seems like Wesley
and Fabi have borderline clinch their
spots right because Wesley's already in
division one next time he'll get some
points and so those two guys are likely
in Toronto but you've got you've got a
third spot now because Magnus won this
event that is going to go to to somebody
right there so it's actually fascinating
again that third spot only opened up
because Magnus just won this but if you
assume Wesley and Fabi will continue to
perform it's really going to come down
to the wire for that final spot yeah I
think the last event also is going to be
really really exciting I mean it kind of
looks like Wesley's safe there but I
mean uh you know those other places I
mean anything can happen last event or
two yeah it looks like Wesley and uh
Fabiano have insurmountable leads but we
saw in 10th Place Dennis lazovic for him
this final that he's playing right now
could be critical and I mean we could
come down to a situation in the final
Tour event we're looking at division two
division three watching a game there
because yeah it might come down to those
uh few points and uh yeah these
standings it's a great big time yeah
plenty of time for a shake-up and we can
see
for anyone now the auction continues
there's so much to play for it's going
to be a 500 000 season and final and
what a week of Chess we've had so much
drama the aim test Rapid David what was
the highlight for you this week
it's got to be Eduardo rosago's dream
run doing so well winning all of our
hearts uh I probably stole uh everyone's
answer there but uh for me that was uh
yeah the highlight Simon getting some
free Puma gear
got some nice trainers out of it cheers
guys
uh highlight of my week was sitting next
to this guy working next to him um I
have to quickly mention utirizaga and so
turning it around because those things
kept us focused and in it and Andy
turizaga the heartstrings but this this
has been great it's been fun it's been a
load of fun definitely guys
yeah we can do a little hug here we go
hold me
I've got you man we'll be back with the
next event it starts mark your calendars
from August 30th there will be the plans
before don't miss it at all we will be
back with the Champions Chester goodbye
chat
oh hello
and that is it Wesley resigns
wow Magnus Carlsen with the black pieces
Deliver Us Checkmate there he is water
performances had today in his Grand
Final
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
box
ES
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign